if we were to look at ourselves through
the lens of an experiment like we would
an animal experiment we think that
animal is sick if you saw an animal
digging in the corner looking looking
looking looking for a bone the dog is
looking looking looking looking looking
you'd think that's really sad that's us
right that's us i'm pointing at myself
intentionally that's us
dr andrew huberman welcome to the show
great to be here it's been a long time
coming very long time coming what do you
mean when you say you cannot control the
mind with the mind
yeah that statement really emerges from
the fact that
if we are in a pretty relaxed state
or if we are happy
we generally feel like we can
do what we want to do we can maneuver
through our environment
we can make choices that are reasonable
but
oftentimes we're not in relaxed and
happy states that's just part of the
human experience obviously and there is
a fundamental feature to the nervous
system
which is this thing they call the
autonomic nervous system which is just
fancy nerd speak for the components of
your nervous system that raise your
levels of alertness or bring them way
down sometimes we hear fight or flight
rest and digest but this
system governs all that but a lot more
and
basically what happens is when we are at
the extremes
of the autonomic what i call seesaw of
very very alert to the point of being
really stressed or panicked or concerned
or if we are very close to sleep and
we're drowsy and we're exhausted
at those
points along
the
autonomic
nervous system
our thoughts become a bit like a runaway
train you know if you're very upset it's
hard to talk yourself out of it if
you're stressed it's hard to think
yourself out of it in fact you can start
doing all sorts of third personing and
rationalization you can call someone you
can text somebody it's very hard to get
yourself out of those states with
thinking alone
but the beauty of the autonomic nervous
system is that
it traverses the brain and the body and
it connects to essentially all the
organs of the body
and it's a two-way street
such that certain behaviors
even certain patterns of breathing
etc allow us to
shift where we are on the autonomic
continuum
between very very alert and stressed and
very calm and thereby give our mind
a shift also in terms of the kinds of
thoughts that we can entertain the sorts
of actions that we can engage in to make
this concrete if you're very very
stressed you're very upset
two things happen one it's very hard to
take your focus off whatever it is
that's upsetting you and if you don't
know what's upsetting you know pure
anxiety but you don't know why it's very
hard to take your mind off of the
feelings of anxiety
in those states of mind
there's another component which is that
for whatever reason and no one really
understands why this is it feels as if
the state that you're in will go on
forever now when we're in happy relaxed
states rarely do we think gosh this is
going to go on forever and yet when we
are in these unfortunate states of mind
we get the idea somehow it sort of
hijacks our perception of time and we
feel like this is never going to stop
if we turn to the body and certain
behaviors
let me talk about what those are
we are able to move ourselves along the
autonomic continuum and at that point
when we've done that successfully it's
actually quite straightforward to do
we are able to think about things
differently we start to get a sense that
the way we feel
might not be the way we're going to feel
forever and
it's in those shifts that we start to
realize ah
my mind actually is not my best friend
at these extremes but there's a lot more
to it you're only getting the tip of the
iceberg in those states so
that's why i say if you can't control
the mind with the mind
look to the body to control the mind
how would that be adaptive how would it
be adaptive for us to focus all of our
attention on to the anxiety is that
something that you could see a useful
absolutely so let's take stress as an
example and this could be stress panic
anxiety you know each one of those has a
definition in medical terms
psychological terms but to be fair
no one really knows how to draw the line
in the brain between fear and stress and
anxiety but we can say with certainty
that all of those states
involve high levels of alertness high
levels of awareness sometimes for things
in our environment and sometimes just
for what's going on
internally when we are stressed anxious
afraid
waking up in the middle of the night
doesn't matter what triggered it there
are a couple basic things that happen to
all of us first of all our heart rate
quickens that's kind of an obvious one
fuel from
our muscles and our liver is shuttled to
particular organs of the body and away
from others
in particular fuel is shuttled towards
the big muscles of the body to generate
large movements this is why we quake a
bit when we're stressed the hands will
shake it's preparing us for we are
prepared for movement how does that
prepare us for movement um the shaking
actually is the consequence of trying to
not move when we are stressed basically
this is why taking a walk or a run you
actually feel like you can kind of
dispel the stress you're not actually
dispelling the stress what's happened is
it's like the arp the rpm are getting
cranked up it's like idling it
right it's you know you could sit there
in a parked car and do that but
basically you take the thing out of park
and it just wants to go and so a lot of
the times when we're stressed it's in
conditions in which we're trying to
remain still
public speaking and a tough argument you
know at the doctor's office about to get
an injection you know it depends on what
stresses people obviously but that
readiness for action is a second
component so heart rate readiness for
action by way of shuttling
glucose and
other fuels to the muscles
and then away from the reproductive
organs from digestive organs etc because
that is just not the right time for that
another very very powerful feature of
this response
is that our our pupils of our eyes the
dark parts of our eyes get big now you
might think that that expands your
visual field but actually the way the
optics of the eye work that narrows the
aperture of your visual field so when
you are stressed you literally are
seeing things through a small aperture
so to straw view of the world as they
say
and under those conditions you cannot
see things in your periphery
as well as you
could prior to being stressed but you
become exquisitely good at measuring
small detailed changes in whatever it is
that you happen to be looking at now
there's a internal process too which is
that the aperture on your thinking also
becomes very very narrow so that if for
instance well i had this happen the
other day
i i heard something very stressful i
couldn't think about anything else
right and that might just seem logical
like of course you can't think about
anything that's very stressful you're
concerned about this but my mind wasn't
thinking about this particular incident
it was thinking if this then this then
if that then that and that then that and
so you start you know dropping into the
future you start dropping into the past
like ah god why did we do that wow you
know and you start doing all that kind
of cycling through things
and of course there are so many things
that can help relax us meditation
exercise a nice healthy meal social
connection but the fifth column of the
stress response is that
your aperture of vision your aperture of
thinking gets very narrow and it becomes
harder and harder to do the very things
that would keep you out of stress
and so this is kind of the the
double-edged sword that is stress and so
all the more reason why in those moments
if the stress is not desired because
there are moments when stress is desired
you're navigating an emergency etc but
if you don't want to be in that narrow
aperture of thinking and vision etc then
you need to find some way to bring your
level of autonomic arousal as it's
called down slightly so that you can
start thinking about other possibilities
or
you know there are instances i think
everyone's been in this kind of
situation where the thing that's
stressing out is not going to get
resolved today
and you just sleep and of course you
know you need to sleep and then you
can't sleep and then of course that
creates a compounding stress and now
you're stressed about not being able to
sleep and then over the course of the
next few days you you know dissolve into
a puddle of tears
but fortunately there are ways out of
that kind of self-destruction you've
done a lot of work on fear that was one
of the things that you mentioned before
is there something that everybody is
scared of because i've heard
the
story the wives tale babies are born
with is it fears of heights and loud
noises or something is there any truth
in that or is there something everyone's
scared of there is i think the one that
um
everybody who has a healthy nervous
system will react quite robustly to is
if you start increasing the amount of
carbon dioxide
that they're breathing and reduce the
amount of oxygen that they're taking in
that's terrifying am i right in thinking
there's a
experiment you can do where it's a
single breath
and that is pretty reliable at bringing
on an anxiety attack yeah if you have
people please don't do this because you
need the right proper medical staff
around but they're they're great
experiments of having people breathe
carbon dioxide directly and it
you basically panic
um it's terrifying yeah one big gulp of
carbon dioxide will make make you very
afraid it turns out that there are a
little group of neurons of course
neurons are just nerve cells that little
group of neurons
in the brain stem that respond to levels
of carbon dioxide in the blood turns out
the reason we breathe is of course to
bring in oxygen and then off low carbon
dioxide
but
we don't have neurons that stimulate
breathing for oxygen we have neurons
that sense when carbon dioxide levels
get too high so if you hold your breath
eventually carbon dioxide levels go up
and then at the moment that they reach a
certain threshold these neurons fire and
trigger the gas reflux
so in that moment you bring in oxygen
and then of course you offload some
carbon dioxide
that's why it's so important to work on
co2 tolerance right for breath work yeah
so
free divers
a sport i actually don't recommend
because there's only one way out of that
sport as they say i have some friends
who are free drivers and obviously you
can do it safely with the right guide
and training etc but it is a very
dangerous sport because for most people
when carbon dioxide levels increase in
the bloodstream and brain triggers this
gas reflex what
free divers train is carbon dioxide
tolerance so they do that a couple of
different ways and again please don't do
this because you actually people have
died doing this which so one way is you
can do what's called cyclic
hyperventilation
right you do that 25 times or so and you
think oh you're bringing a lot of oxygen
you are but you're also offloading a lot
of carbon dioxide especially if you use
forceful exhales normally humans breathe
through active inhales
and passive exhales you just they just
sort of dump their air passively
but if you do cyclic hyperventilation
you're dumping a lot of carbon dioxide
and then if you were to
hold your breath what you would find is
you could hold your breath for a lot
longer why because your carbon dioxide
levels are reduced so you don't have the
same impulse to breathe now on land
that's a more or less safe thing to do
provided that you can get a good gulp of
air once the gas reflex hits
if you do that before going underwater
cyclic hyperventilation they call air
packing
and then you go under water
you're going to be able to
excuse me cyclic hyperventilation to air
pack and then
go underwater
but your
carbon dioxide is then lower you're
going to be able to stay under longer
but this is very dangerous because
normally when that carbon dioxide
threshold hits
you would
pop up to the surface you sort of panic
and want to go to the top free divers
learn to tolerate
high levels of carbon dioxide in their
bloodstream and stay very very calm the
way they die is very interesting
because it speaks to the physiology the
way they they die is they'll just be
swimming
feeling completely calm because they're
very used to they've trained up this co2
tolerance carbon dioxide tolerance and
when they die they don't suddenly feel
like oh my goodness i'm running out of
air it's just
lights go black that's it they're just
blackout and so they're alive and then
they're gone and so this is why they use
spotters they you know they have a line
etc anytime you hear about somebody
dying doing free diving it's rarely
because
they weren't
comfortable at a given depth or because
it's not because
their gasp reflexes kicked in it's
because their gas reflex has been so
desensitized that it's after the point
at which they die precisely and this you
know it's sort of like when you hear
that um
skilled parachuters die why well because
they're so comfortable with so many
jumps they actually forget to pull
they're sometimes there are many
instances in which they're they're uh
videoing
the first time jumpers right and they're
getting the video for them and they
themselves forget to pull because
they're so comfortable jumping out of
planes and so as people get more and
more advanced in something there's a
there's a new risk that that surfaces
because unless it's very reflexive and
they built all all the protocols in
oftentimes they can overlook the very
thing that allowed them to become expert
in the first place why do my palms get
sweaty when i watch videos of people
climbing up cranes and stuff like that
you know the ones that i mean the guy's
got a gopro's a dude called james
kingston from the uk that's a psychopath
he goes up to the highest
uh towers of dubai
illegally in the middle of the night and
then i watch it on a screen it's only
this big
and
i get this visceral response yeah well
two things first of all i i can relate
you know i saw the free solo movie with
alex honold and you know he lives
and it's still scary to watch right you
actually know the outcome at the
beginning they sort of make it clear
that he manages to do this and
you're it's still terrifying and i think
it's for the same reason that those
youtube videos are terrifying
which is
that we are so visual as animals we are
so visual i mean
rodents even a lot of carnivore
predators are extremely olfactory smell
driven
humans are incredibly visual i mean more
than 40 of the human brain has something
to do with vision visual navigation eye
movements um
visual perception color perception face
perception we have dedicated areas of
the brain that are just for perceiving
human faces and these micro expressions
of human faces so so highly evolved for
us
when we see
depth of field
that's not
um
parallel to the ground
it is terrifying with good reason
because
you know what's the universal force that
we all experience from the time we're
born is gravity the first thing you
learn is that things fall down not up
right the you know it's it's like the
the fundamental rule that we come into
the world with it's like
day one even though the baby is kind of
flopping around like a potato but can't
even hold its head up the eyes are often
you know the ocular muscles of the eyes
are often not very good so babies will
kind of eyes are rolling back in their
head that generally corrects itself
over the next few weeks or so
but the feeling of gravity of them you
know if they feel like they're being
dropped even the tiniest bit right they
will go wide-eyed so there's a built-in
vestibulo ocular reflex so when you see
depth of field in the direction of the
gravitational pull
you actually get a little bit of
activity in your cerebellum which
literally means mini brain a little area
of the brain in the back that actually
looks like a little mini brain if you
were looking at the brain and that area
of the brain is responsible for all the
reflexes associated with the falling
reflex it does a lot of other things too
so when you see that depth of field in
the direction of gravity
there you have a little micro activity
in your brain that you might fall
if you've ever been to a tall bridge or
a dam and you go to the edge and you
know people love to play with this
there's that also that tower in toronto
they have that big um
tower well the big no the big um the big
tower i forget what it is maybe it's in
calgary goodness canadians are gonna
hate me okay i love canadians but for
some reason i can't remember this they
have one of those glass floors there
where you can walk and it's terrifying
and you know you're not going to fall
through it right there they tell you
you're not going to fall through it but
it's terrifying
because your
body and brain are preparing for this
immense fall so when you see this in
video it's the same thing i always say a
picture is worth a thousand words but a
video is worth 10 million pictures i
mean this is the reason why we're so
drawn to things like instagram scrolling
it's like text text video
you know or the enormous popularity of
tick-tock
it's video now the enormous popularity
of twitter still escapes me because
that's a different different sort of
cultural gravitational pull but video
and in particular action that gets us in
a kind of a primitive mode that is an
extremely alluring visual image what
about emotional fears like uh fear of
failure or social disapproval or
something do they work in a in a similar
way or is there a different part of the
brain that's using that yeah great
question so um a few years ago a postdoc
in my lab was now a staff scientist
melissa gilman excuse me melissa dr
melisse gilmez balban she has a long
name um excellent researcher studies
fear
did a very broad scale survey of the
general public thousands and thousands
of entries um created this kind of uh
cloud of bubbles the bigger the bubble
the more the greater number of people
that had that fear you saw some we saw
some interesting things so heights
certainly public speaking certainly
doctor's office and syringes certainly
public speaking fear is very common
um social isolation fear is very common
but we also saw some things like dogs
you know there are a number of people
who are afraid of dogs which is
inconceivable to me because i love dogs
so exactly the same yep but people
you know people form these associations
whether or not through experience or
through indirect experience observing
others
i think public speaking is one of the
greatest fear of dying
yeah i i don't it's not funny but
figure of speech i
never think about dying and being afraid
of dying i think about all the scary
things that could happen while i'm
living but there are many people who are
just
intrinsically afraid of dying
and so that's that's a big one um
for people that uh don't swim fear of
drowning for people that swim less so
um for people that have some sort of
psychiatric disorder genuine psychiatric
disorder like obsessive-compulsive
disorder which is not just per obsessive
compulsive personality but obsessive
compulsive disorder
fear of the sh of being discovered and
the shame that they have around their
obsessions and compulsions these are
true ocd is very common do they all live
in the same place
all of these different fears
so yeah so i was rattling off and i
didn't answer your question um to the
the more important point so forgive me
the short answer is they have a final
common pathway which is increased
autonomic arousal and that is funneled
through a couple what we call limbic
structures among others so there's
certainly involvement of the of the now
famous amygdala
this which means almond is this almond
shaped structure on the two sides of the
brain
there's also area of the brain called
the striatum analysis also involved in
fear and then the hypothalamus this
small collection of neurons just above
the roof of your mouth which is really
to me one of the more fascinating areas
of the brain harbors neurons that
create a body-wide and brain-wide
response to something that the
higher-order areas of the brain like the
forebrain
see and perceive as dangerous as
threatening so the short answer is yes
it all funnels through hypothalamus
amygdala stria terminalis and autonomic
nervous system that's a final common
pathway
but in terms of the variety of different
things that can stimulate fear and the
ways that they can do that that is
highly contextual so the forebrain this
real estate in the brain right behind
behind the forehead is incredible
because it's sort of free real estate
for you
to customize for your life according to
what happens to you early on so for
instance you might not be at all afraid
of heights
and you say well why is that so well
maybe when you were a kid you were one
of those maniacs that like you know
doing within the states we call them
cherry drops the kids that could swing
on their feet and then jump off the bar
and then other kids are timidly crawling
to the top of the thing don't even want
to go up the ladder to the slide there's
a ton of variation and that variation
does not exist in the kind of deeper
circuitry the final common path
circuitry it exists in the learning that
we experienced early in life one bad
fall
can do it i mean i was bitten very badly
by a german shepherd when i was a kid my
head almost got my eye but you know for
whatever reason i've always liked dogs
anyway but there are other things that
i've experienced that have left
long-term negative imprints so i it's
highly contextual and a lot of it has to
do with what happens immediately after
the bad experience this is why nowadays
there's a lot of legal use of the drug
ketamine after traumas you know this is
all very dark stuff unfortunately but if
you you know you just imagine the family
member that was just in a car crash and
saw their
the driver their loved one impaled onto
the steering column i mean what could be
more horrible than that nowadays if they
come into the emergency room they will
often give them an injection of ketamine
which is a dissociative anesthetic to
get them to dissociate from this extreme
emotional state
so there are ways now to treat this um
and ketamine is used uh clinically at
later periods too didn't you you did an
experiment where you went
uh diving with sharks and i think that
there was a complication and you went
back the next day to redo it i'm going
to guess that this is for the exact same
reason to sort of conquer and um
integrate the experience yeah uh to make
a long story short we went two years in
a row out to guadalupe island where
there are a lot of great white sharks
some of the more expert shark divers
were cage exiting they were leaving the
cage the first year i did not the second
year
i decided i would but the day before i
did i went down into the cage just get
comfortable again down there and i had
an air failure and the safety tanks were
out also and obviously i experienced
extreme carbon dioxide overload and
panic i didn't full-blown panic i kept
enough awareness that i was able to
obviously i'm here um i survived doing a
share error protocol etc but it was a
very bad situation i don't like to say i
nearly died because that's actually sort
of letting the bug in my brain i like to
joke that the reaper came in and um you
know offered me a fist bump and i
offered him a different gesture instead
so i survived
but the next day i woke up very very
distraught because i had this bug in
this loop in my brain i you know this
notion i came so close to to the end and
so i did go back down and i did cage
exit and i don't say that to um suggest
that it was the smartest decision
obviously you're safer on the boat or on
land
i don't say it to sound you know again
tough or anything i did it deliberately
because i did not want to return
home
with this
loop of fear and so i went back into the
traumatic circumstance and obviously
made it out and if you look at all the
successful treatments
for trauma they all involve
getting close to
the
trauma-inducing mindset
exposure therapy gradual and assisted by
a clinician but rarely if ever
are people with serious trauma
encouraged to get as far away from the
feeling of at least not in the clinical
setting this has a lot of implications
for things like trigger warnings uh
colleagues of mine in psychiatry i've
asked them directly what do you think of
trigger warnings and they said
you know i mean there's some logic to it
on the surface but if you really
think about true trauma
and we can define trauma
dr paul conti was on my podcast his
amazing trauma psychiatrist he said
trauma is an experience
is not just a bad experience trauma is
an experience that changes your nervous
system such that it behaves differently
in the future that in a way that's
maladaptive for you so if you look at
all the trauma treatments they're all
about learning to talk about the trauma
even experiencing some of the same
feelings so things like trigger warnings
and all these things that buffer us
against feeling our true feelings
do nothing but prolong the trauma and
prolong and exacerbate fear
you heard david goggins in the lab to
study him for fear what did you learn
from looking at that guy yeah david's
david's great i always chuckle with
david because you know the one thing
about david is what you see on social
media is actually
what you get when you interact with
david we worked long hours one day and i
was everyone was ready to tap out this
was a bunch of people in
silicon valley for a day you know doing
some workshop type thing and he just he
was changing into his running shorts
midway he was going to run to the
airport and he ran to the airport as far
as i know i get his flight i believe so
you know um but there was this moment of
should we continue should we take a
break and he was like no let's keep
going keep going um everything you see
and read and hear about david is exactly
how he shows up it's really wonderful
he came to the lab and he did you know
we have a virtual version of the shark
thing
um which of course is not the same it's
the real experience but for people who
are afraid of sharks it's quite scary
for them and allows us to study fear
david was he's very afraid of sharks
which was sort of uh amusing to me given
that as a seal he had to spend a lot of
time in the water but he was first one
in wanted to do the vr talked about how
he didn't like it but um but that's why
he did it you know constant uh testing
himself in fact i think even though
david's quite successful i think and has
many many options of how to spend his
time i believe this is correct i think
right now he's doing fire jumping he's
um fighting fires in the wilderness by
zip lining in or fast lining in or
jumping out of planes so he's constantly
pushing that uh that friction lever to
create
or build or
further build this thing about leaning
into friction and this is a term that
isn't really scientific but that i
decided to coin because this idea of
limbic friction that when we're very
tired and we need to be in action or
when we're very stressed and we need to
perform in a more calm and controlled
way
there's friction on both sides getting
out of bed when we're exhausted hard
very hard often
leaning into action in a calm and
deliberate way when we're freaking out
like going to give a public lecture if
one has fear of public speaking also
hard so this limbic friction and david
just seems to seek what i call limbic
friction in every domain of life is that
like exposure therapy for limbic
friction then essentially yeah i mean
what you're training and improving when
you're getting better at dealing with
stress
is this ability to tolerate high amounts
of adrenaline in your body and to think
clearly and function well i mean
adrenaline is epinephrine and just a
little bit of physiology it's released
from the adrenals obviously above the
kidneys that gets your body organs
amped up and energized
it can't cross the so-called blood-brain
barrier you have a high restriction
fence that we call the blood-brain
barrier around the brain
keep bad molecules out
adrenaline therefore is released also
within the brain from a little cluster
of neurons called locus ceruleus the
name doesn't matter so when you are
stressed
your brain and your body both wake up
and that adrenaline
hijacks certain systems narrows your
visual focus etc etc if you look at
almost all stress inoculation
protocols
cold water ice bath cold shower cyclic
hyperventilation
those all do the same thing they
generate a lot of adrenaline release in
the brain and a lot of adrenaline
release in the body
but it's different if those if the
adrenaline in the brain and body is
evoked by you that you did it because
under conditions under which you did the
ice bath deliberately and now you're
wide awake and really really alert
there's this feeling that you have
options it wasn't done to you but you
can train up an ability to for instance
think
clearly and calmly um maybe even do some
simple math problems in your head or
maybe try and relax while there's all
this adrenaline in your system and that
carries over so that when you you know
we've all done it you're driving along
the person in front of you stop short
and you're almost in the accident right
there's that moment where you could
panic or that moment where you could you
know road rage or that moment where you
could freak out but if you are familiar
with the feeling of adrenaline in your
brain and body you navigate that in a in
a calmer way how well because adrenaline
is generic there's no adrenaline for the
car crash adrenaline for the heights
adrenaline for the
the uh the relationship situation it's
all the same so we can get better we can
raise our stress threshold as i like to
refer to it and that can be done through
cold water or cyclic hyperventilation
ideally not at the same time but cold
water you know is a universal stimulus
for creating adrenaline release and
there's a big range of cold not infinite
but a big range of cold
in which you can generate adrenaline
without harming your tissue whereas with
heat you get into a very hot environment
or very low oxygen environment you'll
also get a lot of adrenaline but you can
also suffocate and burn yourself so this
is why cold is used in navy seal
screening and training and this is why i
think so many people really like the ice
bath in cold showers has a bunch of
other positive effects but it is a great
trigger for adrenaline
speaking about relationships one of the
most
uh common traumas probably that people
are going to go through is heartbreak
right you're going to be in a
relationship that you imagine is going
to continue forever maybe when you're 18
or sometimes when you're 48 and
then it's going to stop have you thought
about the neuroscience of what's
happening during heartbreak
you know we did so i've done episodes of
our podcast on
love attachment and relationships
which is a fascinating literature mostly
from psychology but also bio biological
literature
and that's mostly about people's
orientation toward attachment so they're
just very quickly
there's the so-called secure attached
style this typically emerges in
childhood when there's a very
predictable care
um caregiver carry a relationship
between child and most often mother but
it can be father too or other caregiver
just so happens that the classic
experiments were done on mothers because
this was in the 1970s and there weren't
as many
reverse role
you know homes etc there were some but
not as many as there are now so
that's one style of attachment the
parent leaves the child gets a little
distraught but then can distract itself
doing other things or just simply do
other things because they have a high
degree of intrinsic knowledge not the
thought but intrinsic
calm the autonomic nervous system
doesn't feel any need to ramp up because
the mom returns then there's the
so-called insecure attachment styles and
they're a bunch of different ones but
those are the ones where
it's really stressful when the parent
leaves it's not clear they're going to
come back and when they come back it's
not clear that there's they're going to
re-establish the bond the child will
feel
supported etc
here's what's fascinating those same
neural circuits
are repurposed for romantic attachment
in adult life the same circuits which
shouldn't surprise us i mean why would
the brain throw away valuable circuitry
but this whole freudian notion that you
know childhood attachment styles map
onto adult attachment styles
that's real that's physiological now one
important point it's not one for one in
the sense that let's say you had a
secure attachment to your father let's
say it's a young a young girl and as a
baby and a young child she had a secure
attachment to her father and an insecure
attachment to her mother
in adulthood and let's say she's
heterosexual so in adulthood she prefers
men as romantic partners this girl grows
up and you might say well she had a good
relationship to her dad so she's going
to have a good secure attachment style
in her adult heterosexual relationships
ah often it's not the case they will
transplant or superimpose the insecure
attachment style to the to the mother on
to male relationships but have great
relationships to female friends for
instance so we have to be a little
careful to not map one for one that's
important so all of that is in us
and then you were talking about breakups
and we did an episode on grief and the
way that grief works in the brain and
nervous system is that there are three
sort of factors that are mapped in our
consciousness and our subconscious and
these are space
time and this notion of closeness which
is attachment space and time is very
simple it's where is the person that i
love and when will i see them next right
i mean if you have a relative that lives
overseas and you know they're alive
you're not going to grieve them you
might really miss them but you're not
going to grieve them the same way you
would if suddenly you get the note
unfortunately that they passed away
and then attachment is how close you are
to them like how critically you rely on
them for
internal
control and support and that doesn't
mean they have to be an immediate
caregiver it could just be like a really
good friend you call them mates over in
the uk right like a really good friend
that just your knowledge of him
just makes you feel good you feel better
in the world you know as a guy who
mostly grew up with kind of a big pack
of male friends i mean i feel strongest
and happiest and most secure in life
when i see something about one of my
friends doing well in life it just makes
me feel good if one of them dies and
unfortunately i'm getting to the age
where a number of them have died
then
you feel like all of a sudden like
goodness like there's a loss internally
right okay that's all sort of obvious
but what's interesting is that the grief
process itself
is about restructuring this map this map
think of it like a tripod it's got three
pieces space time and closeness when
someone dies
it's very confusing for the brain
because where are they in space well the
body is put someplace maybe it's
cremated maybe it's not
we have notions of a spirit and that
depends on one's orientation a soul or a
spirit okay or if you don't then you
don't then where do they go right and
then time when will you see them again
there's the never you'll never see them
again and the closeness component
remains and so there's an untethering of
this map and so there's been brain
imaging studies um beautiful work by
mary frances o'connor university of
arizona showing that if you look in the
brain and people that are in grief from
loss of a really strong attachment the
state of brain and body that gets
flipped on is a motivational state
it's
exactly the same circuitry in the brain
that one sees active if someone very
hungry is put just outside the wall of
some delicious food or if an animal that
really wants to mate
i guess mate with animals you call it
copulate they really want to copulate
with another animal is put just beyond
the wall of that animal but they can
smell them i mean these are highly
motivated desiring states so grief is a
motivated state to
bridge the distance in time and space
and yet it's impossible and so the
process of grief is a gradual waning of
that motivation
and a gradual shift of the memory of the
person into some concept whether or not
it's a soul whether or not it's just the
past whether or not it's their energy
and again it depends on what the
forebrain of that particular person
believes
shifts that concept of that person into
a place where the brain is comfortable
there's no more autonomic arousal
there's no motivation and we've all
experienced this if you've had a loss
and i've had a loss for instance where
my graduate advisor died and i adored
her and every once in a while her
daughter will call me from her cell
phone and she kept the same number on
that phone and the name and everything
so every once in a while it'll ring
barbara chapman and i'll reach for the
phone and then there's this moment where
i'm like oh goodness so anyway i'm going
on and on just to color this with
example but
when there's a breakup
it's exceedingly hard especially if the
person is young you know if you look at
suicides after breakups those are far
more common in younger people than they
are in older people why because the
relationship represents the whole future
they have no concept that they're they
know they're other people but it sort of
feels like the whole world is shutting
down
so
in
breakups what's happened is the person
is no longer available in time and space
this is why when someone breaks up you
literally have to let them go right you
know constant pursuing of them is out of
context is not healthy they have a name
for that it's called a stalker
don't do it um
but it's almost as if you have to
the brain has to think that the person
is gone in time and space this has
become much harder with social media
right because people can check up on
people they can hear from people in the
old days like when i was growing up you
just like took the phone off the hook or
you you diverted your attention
now we are constantly renewing that the
person is still there and so love and
the loss of love and the death grief are
virtually identical it's that
motivational state and this is why it's
so hard to not reach out to somebody
that you really miss and want back i saw
a study last week that
had researchers asking participants to
rate emotional and physical pain of a
breakup they found that women tend to be
more negatively affected by breakups
reporting high levels of both physical
and emotional pain but while breakups
hit women the hardest they tended to
recover more fully men on the other hand
rarely fully recovered i thought that
was very interesting i wasn't too sure
what that meant yeah it's interesting um
it also rings true with my my experience
and my observations it i i think i mean
this could relate to a number of things
and here i'm painting with a broad brush
right but um you know how comfortable
one is
feeling their feelings is male or female
is going to strongly dictate how quickly
one moves through grief this is the same
thing as trauma
the more willing someone is to feel the
full depth and intensity of the feelings
that they associate with that trauma the
more quickly they're going to move
through
the trauma again i'm lifting from paul
conte's word so these aren't mine but
you know people use a number of
strategies they use distraction
they use states like they sublimate to
things like anger
and avoidance of various kinds in order
to not feel the traumatic feelings or
not feel the breakup people will you
know
try and self-suit with alcohol or trying
to sell soothe with multiple new
partners or whatever it happens to be
doesn't work
just extends it because this map of
space-time and closeness needs to be
fractured and the only way to do that is
for the brain to have to confront the
reality which is that
whether by death or by by breakup they
are no longer available it's like the
food on the other side of that wall
is gone it's just not there anymore
uh or that the food that was accessible
now there's a wall in between and you
will not get through it and you know you
can see this actually in animal studies
that are kind of
hard they're actually very hard to watch
you'll see the animal perseverate
literally damage his own body trying to
get through a barrier to something it's
highly motivated to see people do that
post-breakup they usually do that by
talking to everybody about the breakup
um which is its own form of
perseverating on the motivation what did
i do what did i do wrong this and that
and some of that analysis is healthy
some of it's not now why
would one group
be
more of let's just say effective at
dealing with breakups it's probably the
ability to really feel the full
intensity of how sad it is and be able
to confront that and here i'm you know
i'm a male i've only ever lived in a
male body so all i can tell you is that
i think from a very early age um there's
a an ability that at least i'm sure it
transcends to women too um or extends to
women too but learning to pack down
feelings right and so when are we really
talking about when we're talking about
packed down feelings i'm not a
psychologist but what we learn is top
down control for brain to autonomic
control it's the same thing like i don't
want to jump off the high dive or i
don't want to do this public speaking
but i'm gonna i'm gonna kind of like i'm
just gonna force myself i'm gonna david
goggins it right
grief is is an autonomic state
we say it has valence has negative
valence but it's high levels of
autonomic arousal with a negative
connotation because you can be high
levels of autonomic arousal with
happiness right you can be very alert
and aroused and happy you're very alert
and aroused and sad it's very alert and
arousing sad and yet
we learn how to tamp that down
what is tamping down it's
reducing our heart rate it's
going to work each day being a
functional human being you know there's
a lot of that
rather than allowing ourselves to you
know sob uncontrollably into a pillow um
some people are better at this i mean
the late steve jobs was a big proponent
of scream therapies he used to go up
into the hills behind stanford he
actually owned some still owns the
property back there he was really into
you know catharsis cathartic release of
internal state that he felt would allow
him to like return a happier nicer
person he was also kind of well known
for screaming at people in the office so
he obviously had a lot pent up inside
so i think
the better that we can lean into
the emotional states that we fear the
most but in a controlled way where we're
not harming ourselves or other people
the better the more that we try and
avoid that and we try and sublimate or
just you know i've done this so i'm
speaking from experience you know i
would use the anger or the sadness from
an experience to just work 10 10 times
longer ten times harder to just get that
much more focus you're taking that
autonomic arousal that narrow aperture
and that energy and you're putting it
onto something that moves your life
forward so in some cases that's good
because you still need to function and
give but it can give you the
here i'll just say it gave me the
illusion that i was working through
something because you get all the
accoutrements and rewards of hard work
but what you don't do is remap that
space-time
closeness map and then you find i
guarantee
you find yourself five or ten years
later wondering why you're so exhausted
or why certain things in life aren't
going well and it's because when they
say you haven't dealt with the loss you
never actually allowed yourself to feel
the feelings but once you do
it's like a valve it releases you hear
musicians say that the most recent album
was [ __ ] because i didn't have any
heartbreak to work through right and it
is strange how people
it's a difficult thing to pass because a
little bit of it is kind of like alchemy
right a little bit of it is kind of like
turning something that's terrible into
something that's useful and beautiful
it's fuel
but
you're right it is a it's a hiding away
from what it is that you actually need
to do from the work that you need to do
and in a world which is a meritocracy
where people want success and status and
accolade and fame and you go well
enemies and
revenge and bitterness resentment
pretty good motivators maybe i could use
some of that maybe i should go out of my
way to try and put myself into positions
where this motivates me and working out
where that falls on the ledger is is a
difficult one it is and i think it
depends on life stage and it depends on
how one is going to work it out i mean
the the narrative around the shark dive
i mean even as i say it now several that
was 2017 was the second dive when i
think about all that i think that was
crazy i was out there studying fear and
i almost was the professor who died
studying fears it would have been a
terrible end to the story um what was i
doing don't do this don't do this but
you know there are times in our life
where we feel compelled to take on
certain challenges for whatever reason
there's a phrase that doesn't exist in
the scientific literature but it
captures two
components of physiology that are
absolutely factual earlier we talked
about limbic friction
as it relates to creative process and
sublimation of anger and sadness and
creating things from bad
events books music etc
um the words that come to mind are
limbic resonance the
human beings
resonate with these extreme states you
know there aren't many great albums
written about
a good day walking on a sunday in the
park like it's kind of boring i mean
there's the beautiful painting sunday in
the park with george but i'll be honest
it's beautiful but it's also kind of
boring you can look at the details of it
for a while people like intensity the
scream is that you know people look at
that for a long time and it speaks to
the psychosis of the artist etc
you know people don't generally bond
through passive relaxed states unless
they've also been through a lot together
right i mean even think about uh the we
could talk about this separately if you
want but all of us are here because of
the autonomic seesawing that is the
reproductive act it goes from highly
aroused how you refer to it in your lab
scientist autonomic see-saw it is it's
very interesting that the arousal
process is one of increase in autonomic
arousal
in order to get true arousal but then
not so much that it inhibits arousal
then mating behavior and then the the
orgasm response in males and females is
highly what we call sympathetic not
emotionally some it can be i suppose
emotionally sympathetic but from a pure
physiology standpoint it's a activation
hyperactivation of the stress system
even though it has positive valence and
then there's a very quick rebound to the
so-called parasympathetic arm of the
autonomic nervous system this deep
relaxation which
we don't really know why i wasn't
consulted the design phase but we think
that that postcoital bliss and is and
the kind of relaxing the desire to not
run around a bunch more for most people
was to exchange odorant molecules to
increase pair bonding
and even if people aren't trying to pair
bond because people don't always just
make to reproduce
but
that
some of the molecules that are released
in each of the two individuals oxytocin
being the main one
give people a sense of kind of
post-coital bliss and and it's a very
calm one that creates opportunity for
bonding and discussion is all called
like pillow talk there are other forms
of pill
clarity
but for women it might be something
different right of course a different
different name i only speak in the
language of physiology but for both men
and women this happens it creates this
little orb of closeness that is both
physiological and but neurochemical too
so what we can say for sure is that
whether or not it was in vivo or in a
dish we are all here because two parents
right a male and a female unless you're
a condor where two females can produce a
baby this has now been shown right but
as far as we know where a male and a
female reproduce because they each went
through this arc of arousal
not too high arousal extreme stress
relaxation that happened separately or
together because in vitro it could be
fertilization could be separate so the
test of whether or not we get to
reproduce
is actually the ability to to
assuming that people are doing this
together and not through in vitro
fertilization is a test of whether or
not people can coordinate their
autonomic nervous systems now there are
ways around that and to override it but
by and large that's the way humans
evolved in the way all other animals
evolved
now limbic resonance is
a good way i think to describe that
process but that carries over to other
things too an album about an extreme
loss a song or a poem about extreme loss
brings the reader the listener into a
limbic state that's very similar or
approximates what
the creator
experienced right the person who created
that art or that
poetry and in the same way if
something's about a lot of anger you
know if you like loud fast music or
something like that it's an extreme
state it has a gravitational pull to it
there's
again i'm using this language limbic
resonance
rarely if ever do human beings bond
through nothing they bond through shared
experience and you think of what makes
people feel close well there are a
couple things and this has everything to
do with time perception typically when
there's a high degree of limbic
resonance it means that
the molecule dopamine was increased
substantially over baseline at some
point dopamine is almost always
discussed in terms of pleasure but it's
the molecule of motivation drive
and to some extent reward it tends to
narrow our visual focus and believe it
or not dopamine is the molecule from
which adrenaline is manufactured
biochemically you get adrenaline from
dopamine
so these two act as close cousins to put
us into these states of motivation and
have energy to pursue things
when dopamine
is very present in our system
or if you're in the company of someone
else and there's a lot of dopamine two
things happen first of all you're very
motivated narrowing a focus that's one
the other is that the way that you
perceive time is quite a bit different
for instance if you ever had an
amazingly exciting day just tons of
things maybe meet someone new you're
having the best time i mean just think
falling in love and the most incredible
date that you can imagine how it begins
and how it ends it just feels incredible
it all feels like it went by very very
fast and yet when you look back on that
day it seems like so much happened now
think about it opposite situation you go
to the doctor's office and you're
sitting in the doctor's lobby and you're
waiting and you're waiting and there's
no phone reception so you can't scroll
instagram you're waiting and you're
waiting it's incredibly boring it's a
very low dopamine state it feels like it
goes on forever and yet when you look
back nothing really happened so dopamine
changes our perception of time and in
terms of developing human bonds
this has been well established that if
two people for instance go three
different places in a given day
they tend to feel like they know each
other far better than if they stayed in
one place even for a longer period of
time did you know that pickup artists
were weaponizing this about 15 years ago
no it doesn't surprise me but i'm i'm
sorry to hear it it was common held
wisdom in the pick apart this community
that you were supposed to have a three
location date to manipulate precisely
this to make the girl feel like you had
progressed further down the maturation
process of of spending time together
surely there have to be female pick up
artists too uh yeah hello i feel like
that job's probably easier
i can't comment
i i don't know i've never been one going
back to dopamine how just how triggering
are our phones when it comes to dopamine
okay great question
we often hear that
you know the social media getting
dopamine hit after dopamine hit
when we first get on social media after
a wall for the first time or after a
long period of time the amount of
dopamine that's released we think is
quite substantial it's novel remember
dopamine is about novelty surprise and
the sense that we are on some exciting
track that's what dopamine is really
about it puts us into states of
readiness anticipation looking seeking
etc almost always for things outside the
confines of our skin
just to contrast it maybe for a bit more
of a future discussion
serotonin does the opposite when there's
a lot of serotonin in our brain and body
typically it makes us feel satisfied
stated more quiescent comfortable with
what we have in our own immediate sphere
and within us right the comfort of a
good meal the food you have dopamine is
about go go go if you look at somebody
who's high on cocaine or methamphetamine
it's all about pursuit because that's a
very dopaminergic drug you look at
somebody who's taken a drug
and i'm not suggesting people do this
but it really ramps up serotonin let's
say a selective serotonin reuptake
inhibitor prozag zoloft etc
the side effects of those drugs if the
dosages are too high lack of appetite
lack of libido
kind of meh about life you know then so
they'll adjust the dose down that's
because those are serotonergic drugs
so
in in general
when
we are in pursuit of things dopamine is
is quite high so
now you have to remind me your question
because i've set up the dopamine
serotonin smartphones cell phones yes
um forgive me so
the thing about cell phones is when you
first get on there
and you haven't let's say you're no
wi-fi on the flight or something and you
land it can actually be quite
stimulating you get a lot of dopamine oh
there's this oh there's that but very
quickly when you're scrolling on social
media
you're no longer getting the novelty but
you're continuing to do it you almost
don't know why you're doing it at that
point it shifts over to something that's
a bit more like an obsessive compulsive
behavior where that we can define an
obsessive-compulsive behavior where the
obsession leads to a compulsion so the
obsession is a thought the compulsion is
a behavior but the acting out of the
compulsion merely serves to increase the
obsession
right this is very different than being
obsessed with food or obsessed with
cleanliness there's no payoff right
exactly there's no anxiety relief by
carrying out the compulsion with ocd
behaviors
like scrolling social media the dopamine
quickly wanes and then you find that
you're just sort of and we've all been
there you're scrolling like why am i
doing this this isn't that interesting
that is this isn't that interesting now
the algorithms for social media are very
clever and i don't want to demonize it i
you know provide a lot of a lot of my
life is spent on you know on social
media now but
in the algorithms that they've
incorporated function on the the most
powerful
way to keep people doing a behavior or
an animal for that matter is
intermittent random reward a random
intermittent reward that you don't know
when you're going to hit the jackpot so
you're scrolling you're scrolling and
then you see something typically it's
very high what you know in nerd speak
we'd say signal to noise so if you're
reading some interesting things this
came out in the news this came out and
then it's all of a sudden a riot
or
a person that is jumped base jumping off
a building or um you know for people
that are are scrolling looking at bodies
or something like that live bodies
hopefully people aren't looking at dead
bodies but look if something's very
tragic then that has this gravitational
pull and then you what happens is you
start getting
the system working for that next
dopamine hit that you don't know when
it's going to come it's just like
gambling so i look at social media as
initially being very dopaminergic
driving reward surprise and excitement
but very quickly transitioning to
something more like ocd
and the kinds of behaviors where it
looks if you if we were to look at
ourselves through the lens of an
experiment like we would an animal
experiment we think that animal is sick
if you saw an animal digging in the
corner looking looking looking looking
for a bone the dog is looking looking
looking looking looking looking looking
looking you'd think that's really sad
that's us
right that's us i'm pointing at myself
intentionally that's us so we have to
learn to self-regulate the amount of
time
but
that doesn't have to be a process of you
know scruffing ourselves and saying
don't do it don't do it think about it
in terms of the positive the more time
away from something the more positively
reinforcing it will be when you return
and that just to sort of superimpose
this onto the relationship conversation
you know many of us are fortunate to
have partners that we love spending a
lot of time with it's also good to miss
that person every once in a while now
that might be an hour for some people
apart of no communication it might be a
week everyone varies on this on the
spectrum but the idea of missing someone
is that positive anticipation that kind
of pain right it's a motivational state
and then when you see them it's all the
richer so you can
imagine that these dopamine circuits can
be used to more successfully navigate a
number of different things and you know
a lot of couples completely quash the
excitement and the pleasure of being
together not just physical pleasure but
just pleasure of being together because
they just
spend too much damn time familiarity or
they're texting that all the time right
or they're you know and this whole thing
around texting has become a really
interesting test of dopamine expectation
there's this thing called dopamine
reward prediction error if you think the
reward is coming and it doesn't you drop
below baseline levels of dopamine that's
why you should never tell someone that
this restaurant is going to be the best
restaurant you've ever been to in your
life exactly i made the mistake of
telling my girlfriend on the way here i
want her to read this book i'm like this
is an amazing book you should read it
and i caught myself and i thought damn
it i'm actually detracting from how
good she's going to experience the book
tell her it was terrible oh yeah it's
really good though this is the problem
it's hard to do
so um i think the key is to uh
to leverage dopamine reward prediction
error in the best way it's the surprise
that you know if you take kids you're
driving home from school and suddenly
you pull into the ice cream shop
they're going to be so ecstatic but if
you tell them you're going to go the ice
cream shop and it's closed
huge drop below baseline does that mean
if you tell them that you're going to
the ice cream shop and it's open that's
less than not telling them that you're
going to the ice cream shop and it's
surprised correct it's it's they
literally tear out into maxim surprise
is the maximum dopamine release then
successful completion of the missions
as it were is the next and then
unsuccessful is there not an argument to
be made that you would be able to
drag out the amount of time that
dopamine is released for because of the
anticipation
yeah so well and people do this in
relationship quite a lot right
anticipation is the kind of ultimate
fuel
of the courting dance right i mean this
is also but one has to be very careful
because whether or not it's from the
male side or the female side or whatever
variation thereof
there's a you only get so many reward
prediction errors before people start to
predict or associate
low dopamine with somebody or some
experience in other words if you you
know i'll use an example uh not from my
own life but if you say you know we're
going to costa rica on vacation and then
you say listen i have to work
they might understand but that's a
letdown it's a dopamine reward
prediction error in the direction of
lower dopamine they might recover from
it they might not but most people
recover from it if you do that two or
three times what ends up happening you
can model this beautifully and they've
seen this experimentally in animals and
humans then you say okay we're really
going to costa rica this time and you
think well the surprise is going to be
that you actually go the amount of
dopamine that's released for positive
for successful completion of the initial
goal is far lower than it ever would
have been so you can only cry wolf
i suppose that's not the right way to
put it you can only
create positive anticipation so many
times and then create a letdown before
completion that the pro delivery of the
promise has very little impact and so
you have to be very careful with one's
words better to say nothing
than to let somebody down
for sure in the context of human
relationship and you know this plays out
in some
less perhaps uh amusing ways where you
know you look at people who are
successful in life and you always hear
success build success and it's
absolutely true like when students come
to my lab and they do a phd thesis it's
very important for me to get them onto a
research track quickly that they're
going to experience some success because
if they spend
four years and then it fails that's
devastating and then they have to start
over again same thing with kids i mean
getting
some success early on
even if it's low bar success really does
build up one's positive anticipation
and ability to perform well in the
future because dopamine gives energy
remembers the precursor to adrenaline
and the sense that the world is
predictable
now this can go a wrong way too and i
see this a lot with the idea that
everyone gets a blue ribbon this is
terrible too because
if everyone is rewarded every child is
rewarded regardless of how well they
performed if they're all rewarded to the
same level you actually flatten the
dopamine curve and so in that sense yes
everyone might feel
you know celebrated but you actually are
lowering motivation for
the given activity uh this has a whole
landscape of research in back of it
related to intrinsic versus extrinsic
reward the strongest motivation is
always going to be intrinsic motivation
if you reward kids or adults for
something too many times even if they
like that activity the
propensity to do that activity will be
reduced but if you reward without effort
or without success that is devastating
for a nervous system in fact i've gone
on record and i'll say it again and
again and again which is that
dopamine
that
arrives without prior effort
destroys people this is
this is drugs this is uh you know this
is things like cocaine and amphetamine
it's high levels of dopamine with no
effort okay they had to buy it they had
to find it they did whatever it but
that's no there's no physical effort or
mental effort involved in getting the
dopamine peak this is why hard work
followed by reward great working hard on
a relationship and then it gets better
there's a breakthrough or whatever it is
that is powerfully positive
dopamine that just arrives because you
say oh you're here so you get reward
terrible and this is why rewarding every
little positive thing that a child does
with
you know their favorite thing eventually
diminishes the value of that thing and
diminishes their ability to get
motivated on their own it's a very very
powerful system one has to be very very
careful how one leverages it what are
your thoughts on dopamine detoxing is
that legit does it work well up until
about six months ago i would have said
no um but my colleague anna lemke she's
been on the show
fantastic um i have such admiration and
respect she's great yeah yeah just a
brief anecdote i was i directed
neuroanatomy course for the medical
students at stanford i should have known
who anna was and then one day she came
in to give a lecture on dopamine and
addiction and my first thought was oh my
goodness you know have to get her on the
podcast and have to i want her
talking to the world because it's such
powerful knowledge so if people haven't
heard that episode all right go listen
to chris talking to dr anna lemke i'm
going to listen to it i've listened to
all her podcasts that i was aware of but
again we were talking about it's hard
sometimes hard to find podcasts so i'm
going to listen to that um cannot listen
to her enough times
you know
the
the dopamine
you asked earlier about the arc of
dopamine and how long it lasts that the
one of the key takeaways from that book
dopamine nation that i've incorporated
in my own life is that there are certain
activities like cold water that create
long-lasting arcs of dopamine those can
be very useful for putting us into
long-lasting motivational states
so
these are not big peaks and troughs
these are the pain of the cold water
followed by this long long arc of
dopamine wonderful it's kind of an
antidepressant positive motivator
natural stimulus i always say if you
don't have access to an ice bath cold
showers yes will work if you have a
shower that doesn't get cold enough keep
in mind that the original studies
showing this dopamine increase
had people get into 60 degree water
which is not that cold 60 degrees
fahrenheit for 45 minutes to an hour so
your water bill might go up but you
could just draw a kind of cool bath and
get in that up to the neck so because i
realize there are sometimes some cost
barriers to people that not everyone has
an ice bath
no
dopamine detoxing yeah so dopamine
detoxing is something that
apparently today my uh short-term
working memory is off i i swear i can't
yoga mata get that i can't think of any
i'm caffeinated i can't think of any um
pharmacologic reason for it but uh no
excuses um
so dopamine detox i would have thought
was not something real um it seemed kind
of silly to me actually um and i'll tell
you why it seems silly and why it still
seems silly but why it may have some
utility but then anna dr onolemki told
me that it actually can be quite useful
to take some time and space away from
social media certainly from any
addictive drugs that's the treatment for
addiction and restore those dopamine
levels to baseline
now the way that dopamine detoxing was
initially described in the bay area
where it seemed a lot of tech types were
talking about it
was in terms of i heard something like
oh people aren't even looking at other
people's faces
you know they're really kind of living
this like monkish lifestyle like no food
of that they really enjoy no anything
that to me seems kind of crazy and kind
of extreme i mean i can understand not
ingesting a lot of highly palatable
foods you know eating some blander foods
i can understand not um certainly not
doing any prescription drugs or taking
some time off from caffeine caffeine
increases dopamine receptors which makes
the calf the dopamine that's available
more powerful at evoking the dopamine
response
i can understand avoiding certain
substances and behaviors but the idea
that you weren't going to look people in
the eye because there's going to be too
much dopamine i mean i guess it depends
on who you're looking in the eye and how
much their look
positively arouses you but the fact of
the matter is that that's not
that's not a very rational way to think
about dopamine detox but staying out of
you know high intensity
highly rewarding activities
i think could be useful in terms of
reestablishing that dopamine balance and
everything we know from ana's work is
that
dopamine you know if you drive those
dopaminergic states too long addictive
drugs etc people can do this with sex
food drugs gambling
social media all sorts of things
pornography
you know what ends up happening is the
amount of dopamine that's released over
time goes down and down and down and
down and pretty much is traversing into
the territory of pain and then people
again are back to this thing where you
know they're scrolling internet porn
eight nine ten times or hours a day and
then they're wondering like why this
isn't effective for them anymore whereas
it was before
and there's additional issue with
pornography which is not often discussed
which is that remember
guys in particular
the brain is a learning prediction
machine and if
i'm not trying to say that all
pornography is bad but there are
good data to support the idea that
if your brain learns to be aroused by
watching other people
have sex
it is not necessarily going to carry
over to the ability to get aroused when
you're one-on-one with somebody else
right
especially young kids who are consuming
a lot of pornography the brain is
learning
sexual arousal to
other people having so you're going to
program yourself into being a voyager
or yeah or just create challenges in in
sexual interactions with you know with
with peers with a with a real partner
mary harrington has the three laws of
porno dynamics and the second law of
porno dynamics is the law of fap entropy
and it says that whatever you start out
wanking to will get progressively more
intense over time and i think that this
is sort of speaking to that ever ever
sort of escalating amount of
the wildness that you need to watch in
order to get an ever decreasing
stimulus that comes back yeah and you
know here i'm i'm approaching this only
through the lens of biology right i'm
not a you know i'm not a psychologist
and i'm certainly not um political in it
in any way at least not i have ideas
about politics but i just don't discuss
them publicly but the
but the idea here is that you know i'm
not saying
pornography as a stimulus is bad or good
what i'm saying is
it in its availability and it's
extreme forms it's a very potent
stimulus
and very potent stimuli of any kind
extremely palatable food extreme
pornography
extreme experiences like bungee cord
jumping those set a threshold for
dopamine release and
ana will tell you that and i'm sure she
did that the higher the dopamine peak
the bigger the drop afterwards and it's
not that you drop to baseline you drop
below baseline
so
again it's not these things aren't good
or bad they just have to be controlled
in a way because
when people are pursuing dopamine peaks
over and over and over and they
aren't getting them typically it's
because they've been pursuing that
activity
far too often and you're saying perhaps
take a break from that and then maybe a
an ability for yourself your system to
reset right yeah yeah i mean in theory
all the things that we're talking about
with pornography could be superimposed
onto food or could be super posed onto
real sex right um
that one also has to be cautious there
right but
the cycling back and forth between
dopamine and low dopamine states
dopamine fasting as it were but maybe
just low dopamine states these are
natural rhythms that exist in the
nervous system we have to remember what
the dopaminergic system is there for
i'll say it again i wasn't consulted the
design phase but we know as a as a
generic form of motivation in pursuit
you can imagine the human or the animal
that's hungry or thirsty it needs energy
to go pursue the thing so the idea that
you have to eat in order to get energy
that's true but you need energy in order
to get the thing to eat so our nervous
system has energy also that's dopamine
and epinephrine
yes we use glucose and glycogen etc when
we're pursuing things but
the idea here is you're pursuing
something and then either by smell or by
sight you think you're on the right
track so you go down that track and then
ah there it is you know you get some
berries or you get you know let's get
prehistoric about this or you get to
kill
the prey and eat it and then it gives
you energy to continue this pursuit or
to reproduce i mean there's a reason why
humans and other animals seek out
reproduction is that every
every species but certainly humans have
two innate
desires built into them whether or not
they decide to actualize this or not is
the desire to protect young and make
more of its own species every
successful species does that even if
people don't have children in general
people care about children that because
they of what they represent very few
people dislike children i mean there are
a few mutants out there that dislike
children but you always worry about
those kinds of people yeah you were
talking earlier on about the fact that
dopamine can be released
when you set yourself a little goal and
then achieve it and one of the ways that
you encourage your grad students is to
give them a little bit of reward earlier
on so that it keeps them motivated is
this the same mentality that works
during an endurance event when you want
to say i'm just going to get myself to
the next lamppost i've got to get myself
to that hill over there is that the same
dynamic yeah um we can call it
milestoning you just set some milestone
and the key thing here is that and this
is the beauty of the dopamine system
just like the stress system is generic
the fear system is generic it's designed
for a bunch of different scenarios the
motivation system is also generic it can
be
to achieve the next lamp post as a
milestone or it can be five miles as the
next milestone you get to control that
and it so it's completely arbitrary
right i mean that one of the most
brilliant things that was ever said to
me by an extremely skilled psychoanalyst
is so simple
and yet i do think it's the most
fundamental thing to understanding
oneself is that it's all internal right
if you finish a marathon in first place
no one comes along and drips dopamine in
your ear you self-generate that it's all
internal it's all about your internal
representation now that doesn't mean
that there aren't good and bad events in
life but
the fact of the matter is that if you
set the next milestone as
just outside the distance of what you're
comfortable with and you make it there
if you allow yourself a moment to
register that win
you get energy to do to then set the
next milestone and achieve it that
energy is dopamine converted into
epinephrine into adrenaline and this is
why you hear these incredible heroic
stories like i mean i think the movie
sorry i i hate to say it but the movie
was less good than the book but like
lone survivor the marcus latrell story
and the actually i think today or
yesterday might be the anniversary of
operation redwing so all those guys
sadly died except
marcus
and you know he in the movie he sort of
it's like fast forward to where he i
don't want to give it away but where he
basically is the lone survivor but
in the book it's crazy i mean the guy
dragged himself on elbows and knees for
miles and miles and miles right you know
that kind of ability where you hear
about people walking on stubs to you
know these incredible feats of human
endurance and willingness to persist
those
people were able to do that not because
of glycogen or they drank their goo or
whatever the triathletes are always
using it's because of
nervous system
energy the ability to continue to
manufacture adrenaline and keep going
and the and the extent to which that can
continue is no one will ever know i do
believe that humans have a tremendous
capacity to endure and persist
but that few human beings actually know
how to tap into that system except under
conditions of extreme survival and you
also hear from
really good physicians
ones that aren't into woo biology or woo
psychology at all that to some extent
yes there are people that unfortunately
die in their battle against cancer no
matter what but that the
the desire to continue living is a
powerful force in of itself
there may be spiritual components there
may be that's not the business i'm in
you know so and how i don't know the
experiment i would do to test it but
almost certainly setting of milestones
and the ability to generate dopamine and
adrenaline is what allows people to
persist and live longer there's no
question about that one of the best
books that i've read this year is the
expectation effect by david robson
so he is a science writer from the uk
and he looked at
a whole bunch of studies the placebo
effect which everybody's familiar with
right there is a particular expectation
that an outcome is going to come from
some sort of medication and lo and
behold that outcome manifests he found
this across pretty much every area of
anything that you care to care about so
my two favorite studies from this so so
interesting
he realized that uh gluten intolerance
self-report gluten intolerance has
increased from three percent to thirty
percent in ten years so this is the why
there's so many gluten-free options on
the menu they've got thirty percent of
the population to serve yeah so people
need it and he was wondering well what
is it
human biology hasn't changed that much
is it maybe that the foods have changed
and people are responding to that or is
it maybe some sort of expectation
because
the type of news stories they're hearing
about gluten and about how bad it is for
us and inflammation and all this sort of
stuff maybe it's that and people are
expecting it so they brought people into
a lab
they sit them down these people do and
do not have
self-reported gluten intolerances
and they give everybody the same meal
they tell everybody in the room that
it's got gluten in it it's got no gluten
in it
after a while
people who
don't have a gluten intolerance
biologically who haven't eaten gluten
have diarrhea they have hives they're
breaking out in inflammation they're
having to run at the bathroom okay well
that's kind of interesting they did
another
another story that you spoke about
vo2 max tests that they were looking at
apparently there's a particular genetic
mutation that allows people to blow off
co2 and upregulate oxygen in a better
way
they brought people in even numbers of
people that didn't did not have this
genetic trait
split them into two random groups so
there was a mix of both do and do not
have the trait in each first group was
told you've got the right genetic trait
you should be really really good at this
second group was told
sorry you don't have it you shouldn't be
too good
no surprise perhaps at the group that
was told that they did they ended up
performing better but when they actually
looked at what was happening in the
physiology of these people
they found that the people who didn't
have the genetic mutation but were told
that they did
had a
lower overall lactate threshold they had
a lower overall heart rate they were
blowing off co2 more effectively and
upregulating oxygen
better than the people who did have the
genetic mutation but were told that they
didn't so he coined this term that said
your expectations are even more powerful
than your genes i love that i'm going to
read the book i that's a remarkable
example
and i think that you know a lot these
days is being made of epigenetic effects
and things but this is almost in the
different direction this is a
psychophysiological
response
i find this kind of thing
to be honest among the more fascinating
and interesting aspects of neuroscience
if not the most interesting lately
those examples are tremendous so i can't
counter those at all with anything more
spectacular but the the work of dr
aliyah crumb at stanford she runs the
stanford mind body lab and she's done
simple experiments but they're really
elegant um instructing people one group
all about the terrible effects of stress
destroys your immune system etc etc
other people telling them also true
things but all the positive effects of
stress it sharpens your ability of
function you can remember things better
etc etc you see exactly what
you are told basically
now you can't lie to people you can't
tell them things that aren't true it's
just about the subset of information
that you get dictates the response you
get and perhaps the most traumatic was
they gave two different groups of people
and then they actually each got the
opposite condition too a milkshake one
group is told this milkshake is very
high calorie it contains a lot of fat
and sugar etc another group is told uh
the milkshake they're getting is very
low calorie it's very nutrient sparse
etc then they measure hunger so how long
it takes for them to get hungry again
after ingesting it they also look at
insulin
and they also look at ghrelin this
hormone that is secreted um as you get
essentially makes you hungry it's
associated with hunger there are other
things too but
you see exactly what you would expect
which is that people that get the
nutrient-dense milkshake
are satisfied for longer their ghrelin
is suppressed and their insulin is
higher you see the opposite in the group
that had the the so-called low calorie
shake turns out it's the exact same
milkshake
this is remarkable right because
this is not simply the placebo effect i
think it's the placebo effect plus the
expectation effect plus a real
physiological effect because that's what
you describe as well and the way that
ali dr ali krum as she she goes by
the way she describes it is that any
event
causes a real physiological response but
that real physiological response is
braided in with our expectation and our
understanding of what the response ought
to be to create the actual response so
it's sort of real plus perceived equals
your reality right exactly and so um i
love this kind of thing as you can tell
i'm i'm eating up the example that uh
that you gave i think it's spectacular
because
what it means is that no we can't lie to
ourselves we can't tell ourselves that
you know drinking water is going to
sustain us just as food would for uh for
five days we're not going to be hungry
but to some extent if one understands
that well you can survive a long time on
just water yeah you don't need to eat
then you might experience less hunger
that's the way the nervous system works
well you can definitely survive longer
on just water if you believe that you
can survive longer on just water
there is no reason not to believe this
so i was really really averse to the
whole
ronda burn the secret woo sending out
messages to the universe and david
uh positions himself very anti that as
well in the book
but you can't deny the fact that the
positive thinking has a real
physiological impact on what you do he
was talking about um they did a study
with
older people
uh that were past retirement and they
asked them to use what sort of words do
you associate with getting older and
they split these people into two
different groups and the sort of words
that people used perfectly mapped onto
how long they were going to live so the
people that used the sort of words alone
frail fragile injury death
they were the ones that lived the
shortest the people that said um
happiness freedom liberty
connection
uh maturity th those sorts of words were
the ones that lived the longest so
your expectations can literally impact
your longevity there's i i'm yet to read
the book in detail but i've talked to a
guy named ethan cross who wrote a book
called being on the show oh fantastic
okay
i think that internal chatter world is a
very interesting one that neuroscience
will eventually have something to to say
uh about
i think the most powerful mindset
at least to me is one that again i
learned from ali crum
this is a mindset that in her
peer-reviewed studies of different
populations it's clear exists
universally in people in the seal teams
but
less so
or is perhaps even absent from the
general population sadly
[Music]
the idea that stress grows you
that challenge grows you but isn't the
only way that you can grow i think is a
very powerful mindset so what do you
mean by that so they she what they did
is she surveyed a bunch of different um
people different professions and asked
you know what's your view of stress do
you think it grows you it diminishes
your ability etc so this isn't giving
people information this is asking them
for information and the only group that
said stress grows you the more challenge
the better you get etc the more stress
you experience the more likely you are
to to succeed was the this group from
the seal teams i don't know if they were
new recruits or if they had been in a
long time but that was the the group
i would add to that that yes if you
adopt the mindset that stress grows you
you're going to be much better off but
also that stress is not the only way to
grow in life right there's this id you
know we have this and again there's sort
of a gravitational pull of this side
like stress grows yes you know forward
center of mass or you know always be in
friction limbic friction limit friction
how about a more
expansive or nuanced version of that
might be
stress grows you so if you're under
stress you're back on your heels from
something you think okay how can i get
flat-footed or even forward center of
mass you tell yourself stress grows me
stress grows me stress grows me but that
doesn't mean stress is the only thing
that will grow you right learning to
cycle between periods of hard work and
deep what i call non-destructive uh
deliberate reset right
that's what really works over time i can
attest to that you know i people who
just really go out and tie one on in
order to to recover you can only get
away with that for a few years before
your body and mind start to give out
right so find non-destructive ways to
reset
and also adopt the mindset that stress
grows you and adopt the mindset that
you know there are other ways to grow
that don't involve stress and i think
you're set up to have a pretty fantastic
life that's my you know simple view of
of the way these things work speaking of
endurance and suffering
what have you learned from lex friedman
since you've been friends with him
the guy works a lot you can text him or
call him at pretty much any hour except
the early morning hours that he happens
to be in because he's likely to be
asleep you know lexus is a really
interesting one um
because
you know like a lot of scientists and
engineers yet he has that ability to
really drop into the trench which is
certainly not unique to scientists and
engineers but is really helpful i think
lex comes at things from a from at once
a very engineering physics perspective
which you know obviously computer
science robots and all ai and all that
he loves that stuff but you know there's
a phrase that he's used over and over
again in our conversations and he's
talked about this publicly that i've
started to pay a bit more attention to
because he says it so many times which
is you know approach life with love in
your heart you know which is weird right
you think about an engineer who's
thinking like this goes there and this
is what it's going to predict the best
outcome and then anything like approach
things with love in your heart and i
think he's right because and i think
that is very powerful because
there are so many pitfalls
and by pitfalls what i mean are energy
sinks that you know across the day from
the time you wake up until you go to
sleep at night there's so many places
for you to put your energy can go into
online battles it can go into
uh you know texting five different
people it can be investing in one person
it can be there's so many things
and so much of success in any domain is
about yes maintaining focus we hear
about that a lot focus focus focus but
what is focus focus is really about not
allowing energy to dissipate into these
kind of meaningless trails so i think
about lex and i as i do for all people i
think you know what animal does he best
represent or what animal best represents
him i think of all people like this i
have this kind of weird process where
after i spend some time with somebody it
just pops to mind like i can't tell you
what animal comes to mind yet you might
see that after the ice bath later on
you'll see how long it is you might be
you might be a polar bear um super
comfortable in the water um the cold
water but i think that you know at some
point i realized that that lexus gets
very fixated on things very very fixated
but he also knows how to disengage and
he really avoids energy sinks through
this and losses through this kind of
love thing that he's really into um
because anger is very energetically
demanding it's great fuel but it's not
efficient fuel overall right it's like
having a gas tank full of fuel but there
are a lot of leaks in it whereas i do
think that doing things out of genuine
desire there's a calm
sort of energized balance that comes
with that and you feel like you can go
forever so this is starting to sound a
little bit woo it sounds like oh you
know the heart is more powerful than the
adrenals and like they're both powerful
the adrenals can keep you alive and
enduring for a long long time but if you
do things out of anger and friction for
too long your immune system will crash
we know this
but it is
essentially infinite how much energy you
can derive out of genuine desire
to engage with something or somebody
well anonymously then
you know lex well his hair makes me
think some spiky thing he's sort of like
he's some he sort of has the like the
persistence of the porcupine but he has
he's definitely has i think he as much
as i don't want to admit it because i
wish it were me and not him but i think
the animal that best captures lex
because he's also a bit of a loner is
the wolverine i've spent a lot of time
thinking about actual wolverines not the
hugh jackman version of wolverines but
the actual wolverines they're very solo
animals unless they pair up to mate they
are incredibly strong he is freakishly
strong i've done jiu jitsu with him i'm
not good at jiu-jitsu he is he's a black
belt jiu jitsu but he is freakishly
strong so if i had to pick an animal i'd
say probably um the wolverine what's
interesting about him i went to
thanksgiving with him last year which
was my first time of enjoying that
holiday here which is a fantastic
holiday i actually think we don't have
something in the uk where people sit
back and do that gratitude reflection
period except for christmas you know
people do that end of year review but i
really think and especially the time of
year it's in it's perfect so
we were talking and
he was talking about the fact that he
was working hard but he feels this gap
between where he is and where he could
be which i i sounds like sense is a
common uh pattern yeah and
he was saying that a lot of the friends
that he speaks to will say you know
you're doing well you're working hard
and
he looked me in the eyes and he's like i
don't want them to say that i want them
to tell me to suck it up i want them to
tell me that i need to stop being such a
[ __ ] and keep going i was like it takes
an unbelievably singular person to work
as hard as he does i don't think that
the internet
whatever people know about how hard he
works
is only a small sliver of just how
obsessive and and committed he is and
for him to say that he wants to be
around more people that push him in that
way it made me realize that
perhaps uh i could be offering more to
my friends as well that offering them
just sort of
support in the form of acceptance and
and presence and i'm hearing you and
dude you're doing great or whatever
reassurance in that way maybe isn't
always the best way to go about things
so yeah that was it's just something
that stuck in my mind it's something
it's a little model that i've kept with
me where i'm thinking look does my
friend need me to tell him that he's
doing good or does he need me to tell
him to suck it up and get his nose down
because i know that he can do it sounds
very much like lex i'm learning about
your your internal workings a bit too
there are three kinds of reward two of
them are often discussed one is rarely
discussed but is pretty powerful and i
think it's useful to think about
toggling between these different rewards
whether or not for ourselves or whether
or not in trying to
stimulate and motivate other people
one of course is reward you did great
congratulations that was awesome loved
that podcast great that you got an a
plus on your report card or b plus
because last year you got to see
whatever it is reward then there's
punishment right
this is obvious you screwed up like
you take something away or you take the
anticipation of reward away whatever it
is you screwed up you're punished you're
grounded etc you're not watching tv for
a month or whatever it is no screens for
a month then there's the third kind of
reward which is the reward that you hang
out in front of somebody at a distance
like a carrot on a stick out in front of
them which is not reward for what
they've accomplished but reward that
they can anticipate if they accomplish
something i think this could be
very effective in the context that we're
talking about it which is how would i do
this with lex i'd say you know i really
loved this particular interview
if only the next time you have that
person on you also ask them this right
that's not a punishment you're not
saying it sucked because it didn't
include this you're not saying it wasn't
great you're saying
if next time you were to do that
i think it would be even better so
you're hanging a potential reward out in
front and i think that can be a very
powerful motivator so you can you know
we could build up a number of different
examples around this but this is not
often talked about in sort of reward
punishment schedules and motivation we
always think reward and punishment but
we think immediate reward immediate
punishment
now in terms of building habits
and goal setting and goal seeking we
know
that visualizing failure is
for better for worse is a far better
motivator than visualizing success if
you want to get people motivated to
start
right
to start now getting people to continue
involves regular rewards for reaching
milestones however and i should have
said this earlier i want to make sure
that we do emphasize that the best
schedule really is random intermittent
reinforcement so if you're setting
milestones on this run or in your
intellectual pursuits or business
pursuits or relationship pursuits if you
set a milestone and you get there you do
want to
have a little bit of an internal
celebration remember it's all internal
so internal celebration not extrinsic
celebration
and reward
but every once in a while it's good to
just not reward yourself now at what
ratio should you do that well the the
computer modeling data say that the
optimal ratio of success successful
trials and uh unsuccessful trials for
learning and motivation is going to be
about 85 of the time to reward yourself
and about 15 of the time to not reward
yourself so random intermittent lack of
reward is another way to think about it
and i talked about this with jocko a
little bit and he thought oh yeah
probably what we should do is have
workouts where it's a big uh fishbowl
full of ping pong balls and about 15 of
them are marked with reward but the
other ones is you do something and you
get to go take a ping pong ball out and
if you take that out then you get some
reward
if it's marked and if it's not then you
don't
and rather than every time you
accomplish something you go reward
yourself so here we're talking we're
getting kind of into the weeds of reward
schedules but i think if you really want
to support a friend punishment you
should use very judiciously although if
they really screw up a good friend as
they say will put um the friendship
ahead of the friend or the friend ahead
of the friendship excuse me um the
friend like you're gonna tell them what
they really need to hear even if it
compromises the friendship if you really
believe they need to hear that
other times reward like that was awesome
congratulations and then
occasionally if it's warranted
that was great ish
but it would be so much better if the
next time you did this or that was great
but you know honestly i think it was a
mixture of good and not so good so i
think those are three powerful ways to
reward and they can be mixed up and
toggled back and forth according to
whatever schedule allows that person to
continue what does your morning routine
look like at the moment
morning routine is wake up
if i
run about what time uh i'm waking up
these days around
6 a.m 6 30 a.m i'm trying to go to sleep
by about 10 30 p.m sometimes it's 11
sometimes it's 10.
i wake up
um and i have to be careful here because
whenever i've described my routine in a
little bit of detail people always say i
can't believe you don't go to the
bathroom and it's like well of course i
so i wanted my pants exactly right foot
left so i want to be clear i yeah i take
care of my basic functions um but when i
wake up i make a beeline for sunlight
uh so i'm gonna get sunlight in my eyes
for the you know i'll probably go into
the grave saying this so forgive me if
people heard me say this before but the
single best thing you can do for your
sleep your energy your mood your
wakefulness your metabolism is to get
natural light in your eyes early in the
day don't wear sunglasses to do it takes
about 10 minutes or so
if you live in a cloudy area if you're
in the uk in the winter yes or the
summer or the summer maybe you resort to
some artificial light as a replacement
but
as much as one can get bright
natural and if not natural artificial
light in your eyes early in the day
without sunglasses
contacts and
eyeglasses are fine don't try and do it
through a window or windshield it's
going to take far too long this sets in
motion a huge number of different
neurobiological and
hormonal cascades that are good for you
reduces stress late at night offsets
cortisol a million different things
really that are good for you so i get
that
and yes somebody does that walk doing a
little walk ideally that would be a walk
but sometimes we'll just go into the
yard and have some coffee and and
you know soak into whatever sunlight
through through the clouds if it's a
cloudy overcast day it might be 20 30
minutes if it's a
um it's a very bright day it might just
be a few minutes but really the the
quality studies on humans that have
looked at this say try and get as much
natural light as you can in the morning
hours whenever it is that that is for
you especially the first three hours
after waking if you can work outside
great if you can get in your window
because as opposed to just in a dark
conference room that's better but if you
can get outside that would be fantastic
so i i get sunlight i hydrate i drink
water and then yerba mate is my favorite
form of coffee excuse me caffeine are
you waiting how long are you waiting for
90 to 120 minutes are you doing any
salts during that time are you taking
any electrolytes in i am a fan of water
with element before i
had element packets i would just take a
little bit of sea salt or or pink sauce
your favorite element flavor
i like them all there's one i don't like
i'm not a fan of the chocolate one but i
like that yeah some people love it my
podcast producer his wife loves that so
i give it to her the chocolate mint one
but um i like the raspberry the
um the citrus one i love that stuff
mango chili is if you open the mango
chili and breathed in shortly afterwards
it's like being pepper sprayed it's
absolutely insane it's like it's like
being blasted in the face but yeah i
mean that's that's just the best way
that cold glass of water and that first
thing in the morning and i mean it was
you who uh
reassured me of the what i thought was
bro science about your adenosine system
not being active for the first 90
minutes and if you're going to pump
caffeine onto that you're not really
actually acting on that your adrenal
system is the one that you need to be
looking at optimal you hydration all
that sort of stuff it's just such a good
way to start the day so okay we've got
um 90 minutes deep what have you been
doing in that you've had your light in
the eyes what have you been doing
between that and the yerba mata in 90
minutes
i do everything i can to
not do email not do social media and to
take care of a few critical tasks these
days i'm i have this obsession with
trying to do one
cognitively hard thing a day
one
and one physically hard thing a day now
does not extreme physical not david
goggins level workouts or anything but
um
in that 90 minutes i'll typically try
and read a research article start to
finish or i'll work on a document that i
might be doing a grant or research paper
or planning a podcast or researching a
podcast
i try and get my brain into kind of a
linear mode i try and narrow that
aperture
so if i don't the distraction that's
created by social media and interactions
with others can kind of wick out into
the rest of the day so i'm not
necessarily trying to finish something
in that time but i try and do something
challenging i experience great
pleasure from
battling through something mentally
challenging but that's something that i
built up since my university years when
i was about 19 or so got serious about
school and
really started to
experience the the deep pleasure of like
ah i figured that out or like that was
really tough i don't always succeed but
that's what i'm doing in that hour to 90
minutes
but i confess sometimes
we'll take a walk during that time and
maybe talk through some things that are
that are challenging you know or
sometimes i get lazy and and i'll miss a
day of that cognitive challenge then i
do caffeine about 90 to 120 minutes
after waking and
even though i prefer to work out earlier
i generally will then do some sort of
physical workout i have a very
consistent routine i've done over 30
years where i weight train for 45 or
minutes to an hour every other day and
occasionally i take an extra day off and
occasionally due to travel or other
commitments i'll occasionally double up
two days and then take two days off yep
so it's really boring you know talk
about workout schedules but it's really
simple it's like you know i'll do a uh
kind of pushing day rest pulling day
upper body push up rest upper body pull
rest and then legs take two days off
something like that are you doing on the
off days are you doing some sort of zone
three
always jogging or skipping rope those
are my favorite forms of cardio
sometimes swimming but typically i'll go
running for 30 to 45 minutes
or if i'm feeling a little bit lazier
because i always find the high intensity
stuff to be easier than the long drawn
out stuff
i'll sometimes throw on a weight vest a
30 or 50 pound weight vest and i'll go
out for a shorter run or i'll i'm a big
fan of knees over toes ben patrick i
know you had him oh yeah
we were down in costa rica with him and
his wife who had the best time and
learned so much um i'll occasionally
um do a backwards you know he'll walk um
or throw on the weight vest for that we
sometimes will get bands and we'll so
there's a great way to combine this
we will sometimes get two people in one
of these thick bands do hill walks in
the morning while getting our sunlight
yeah but that i don't really consider a
workout i consider that just kind of
rehabilitating as a movement so on the
off days i'm doing cardio and sometimes
that's the morning sometimes that's in
the evening i do not like to wait train
on the second half of the day because i
like to be really caffeinated when i
train i like to listen to loud fast
music
most of the time not always i keep my
phone
out or off of for most workouts
podcasts maybe if i'm running but i
really try hard when i'm working out to
just focus on the workout and those
workouts the weight training workouts
are always 10 minutes or so of warm up
and then no more than 40 to 50 minutes
of really hard work if i do train hard
any longer i don't recover enough to be
able to come in a few days later and
when i train that way i generally make
pretty consistent progress and you're
taking yourself up until what's that
probably maybe 10 30 11 a.m something
like that yeah and then i'll eat my
first real meal now occasionally i'll
wake up really hungry if i didn't eat
that well the night before but typically
the after i train i yeah i'll eat i like
oatmeal after i train oatmeal fruit some
fish oil protein drink and then maybe 90
to 120 minutes after that i'll have a
real lunch my lunch is pretty much the
biggest meal of the day if i have my way
it'll be a steak a salad maybe a little
more starch although i sort of got it
earlier um
brazil nuts and that meal sometimes can
extend long-term
i love being a feeding person i love to
eat yeah so i'll eat and then i confess
i usually will work a little bit more
for about 30 minutes or an hour
typically email and then i'll take a um
10 to 30 minute yoga nidra nap or a nap
and then come back refreshed
um i really struggled with the naps man
i come back after that and my emotions
are all over the place i'm disoriented
maybe it's because
i struggle to fall asleep super quickly
and therefore i'm extending that period
out for a little bit longer than i need
i probably need to try the yoga nidra
thing but for me it's it i'm absolutely
all over if i do that i wake up and i
don't know what day it is and my
emotions always feel a little bit out of
whack as well i wake up grumpy from naps
sometimes i'm told okay there are a few
times when i've woken up just really
angry i have no idea what that's about i
don't know any of the neurochemistry
associated with that sometimes i wake up
from naps it's really pleasant i'll
occasionally d if the nap is early
enough in the day afterwards i'll have a
you know a nice double espresso get back
into work that's the hardest part of the
day actually if i was well structured in
the early part of the day it's that 2 or
3 p.m
the key is then to try and get something
really useful done cognitively again so
some people might look at this and say
wait you're working for an hour in the
morning and 30 minutes here and an hour
in the afternoon when are you actually
working but
it's really about the depth of the
trench when you're working and so if i'm
going to drop into something again for a
few hours in the afternoon
i'm really going to drop into it and
that's typically phone off and out of
the room and my goal is to get to the
evening time so that i can do the things
that i want in the evening i can enjoy
like i'm always setting a goal of the
next time block so this is something
i've been doing for a long time but even
more so lately i don't think my goal in
the next hour is to do blank i think
this is dopamine reward predictions uh
in action i think okay if i get this
workout done
then i'll be able to eat at more or less
the same time which i enjoy and then
something else will happen so i'm very
focused on what i'm doing but i'm doing
it for the purposes of like opening up
the next door to the next thing so if i
can get that afternoon work block done
i'm thinking if i can just really get
this podcast recorded yeah which i enjoy
is that your usual time to record middle
of the afternoon it used to be in the
morning but i'm getting i'm putting more
and more preparation into them all the
time my poor podcast producer he's like
you know i always joke that the one
thing these podcasts
probably will succeed in doing meaning
my podcast is they're going to cure
insomnia because some of them are so
damn long but i experienced so much
pleasure from spending a week or two
researching something and then putting
some structure on and as you know i mean
podcasting is its own
its own sort of natural drug uh it just
feels good if you enjoy doing this sort
of thing um so typically we're starting
late in the day now and going until
pretty late for me the problem that i
have so i'm fasted right now we're what
one minute to four p.m you haven't eaten
anything today no not this gracious so
but that's the only way if i eat i've my
thoughts become slower i'm not as
verbally articulate i'm nowhere near as
agile now i could push this super super
light i'm sure and it would be probably
a pretty bad idea
maybe i could avoid maybe i could go
protein and fat or just mostly protein
earlier on and that would have avoid but
i just find that my thoughts and my
verbal articulation just goes through
the toilet it's adrenaline if you i mean
i think that sorry to interrupt you but
if you ingest a bunch of glucose or you
know i think you're getting that i mean
you've got to have a nice i'm guessing
if we were to tap your vein right now
if we could do micro dialysis on your
brain that you have a nice low but
steady level of adrenaline and listen
this adrenaline thing this dopamine
thing is no joke this is the stuff of
human evolution right this is the these
are the same neurochemicals this is this
is the energy drink of human evolution
this is not the rock star red bull etc
that stuff just hijacks this very system
i'm not saying it's bad it's just
feeding this very same system so if you
find an eating schedule or a fasting
schedule that allows you to tap into
that as a resource
i don't care what anyone says about
whether or not fasting will make you
live longer or not who knows right
if you're in the control group you know
what's going to happen so
but everyone presumably everyone dies
eventually so pick your pick your mode
of eating be my guest but if you figured
out a way to tap into this
in a way that works for you by all means
leverage that because until somebody
comes along and says that intermittent
fasting is unhealthy well then to me it
seems at least for me eating between 11
p.m excuse me 11 a.m ish and 8 p.m ish
is great and what i can also tell you is
that having a consistent meal schedule
meaning a feeding window we absolutely
know i don't know why this isn't
discussed more we absolutely know that
that helps anchor your sleep schedule
and having a anchored sleep schedule
helps anchor your light viewing schedule
and a light viewing so it all starts to
to piece together i think that what's
lost in the discussion about nutrition
except for the fact that most online
discussions about nutrition are carried
out by the religious well they're
religious but they also seem to be
carried out by people that have like i
don't know like like real feelings of
powerlessness in themselves like it
comes through like because they're
quibbling over like whether or not you
should eat a cracker or not or whether
or not you know um
inhaling oxygen you know westward is
going to break your fast or not i'm
sorry i'm i'm obviously i want you so i
once said david sinclair came on my show
twice and he's he's a fantastic human i
know you're friends with him and um he
talked about the fact that his
resveratrol goes into a small amount of
fatty yoghurt
i think because it's like breakfast
right so you need to mix it in and it's
homemade yogurt and something else and
something else and it's like it's it's a
shot of yoghurt right it's enough for
him to put his little capsule of
resveratrol in and
the comments were alight with people oh
yeah saying right that's not a real fast
this is hilarious because you've got
it's so sad uh you know it's so sad that
we can't have a nuanced conversation
about nutrition online that well let's
let's be fair calories in calories out
applies right i don't think the laws of
thermodynamics have disappeared um
and yet you have people who would argue
that it doesn't and okay like we'll let
them have their their arguments i think
that the key thing is when you find an
eating schedule that works for the other
things that you need to do in life it's
really beautiful
because
then you really start to exert some
control over these energy systems what
we're talking about is focus and defocus
we're talking about focus and deliberate
decompression when not it's yoganidra or
a nap or simply a walk
and food as you point out is a wonderful
source of caloric energy we need it at
some point
but
it also can create this parasympathetic
response where we feel very tired
especially
if you don't eat for long periods of
time and then you eat substantial amount
of starches you will feel
like calmer and more relaxed and so
and maybe sleepy or maybe brain foggy so
i i've been you know of course assaulted
by this for this online i do tend to eat
some more starches in the evenings and
fewer proteins and sure you can show me
20 double-blind placebo-controlled
or randomized control trials saying that
if you're going to eat starches you
should eat them in the early part of the
day well i do that too after i train but
ultimately what i'm interested in doing
is maintaining the kind of bodily health
and aesthetic that i'm looking for my
blood lip is that i'm looking for but i
want to accomplish things in life so i
think if one gets too distracted by
what's possible with nutrition it can be
it can really take somebody off target
no one ever
succeeded in creating anything useful in
terms of work or relationships by overly
focusing on changing their dietary
intake but so
once it works so what once something
works for you
i say just lean into it just lean into
it and that can change over time so that
can really change over time do you know
alex hormozy you familiar with him
sounds familiar really hot [ __ ] on the
internet at the moment this sort of jim
bro who has founded this company and is
now moving on to bigger and better
things he's eaten i'm pretty sure he's
eaten the same lunch
for
10 years or something he always has the
same lunch and he's got the exact same
thought process around this that you do
if you were going back to the morning
routine thing
if you were to design
or if you were to instruct someone to do
the worst possible things in the morning
to set their day up for failure what
would they be
uh wake up and stay in bed uh well wait
there are good reasons to stay in bed in
the morning but once those are completed
then
staying in bed
is curtin's throne yeah curtains drawn
just using your passively scrolling on
social media um
that there are
there are neurobiological data showing
that when you are upright
you actually are stimulating this area
of the brain called locus ceruleus
whereas when you recline you actually
are less alert literally the position of
your body
dictates some of your levels of
alertness that's why you suggest uh
people to not sit like this
uh at their work desk right yes and if
you're look and
if you're looking down
while working you're actually less alert
than you could be if your eyes are
averted slightly overnight most people
that are on their phone including me and
the postural stuff is really bad too i
mean i'm getting i'm trying to really
combat that internal rotation you know
that the c-shaped human kind of thing
you know um it's really not good i'm
really trying in fact one this is so
common now
the c-shaped human thing that um it
almost feels strange to be upright you
know like people think exactly the open
uh the the uh
sort of external rotation is good for us
we know this but in bed i would say in
bed so people are on their phone they're
in bed they're not getting enough light
or they just artificial light or they're
trying to get the sunlight through the
window terrible um
they are then going and sitting and
getting into like hip you know hip
flexor contraction um they're drinking
coffee too early in the day
uh
they aren't getting into any kind of
movement but it's mostly about the sort
of randomization of activities sort of
making a cup of coffee while texting um
not getting sunlight you know then
they're scattering that in with like a
little bit of work but then something
hits that's stressful and they're
diverting their attention they're
building in this eight attention deficit
like disorder
through these they're doing they're not
single tasking they're not monotone and
they're not being deliberate or
intentional with the things that they're
doing they're just allowing the morning
to kind of
come and take them wherever the wind
blows that's right and i have to say
even though i describe my routine
accurate my morning routine accurately
if i were to really optimize it and i've
done this from time to time i would get
up
i would hydrate and i would immediately
exercise
i would use that early you know peaking
of the cortisol response that comes with
waking to get the body into action sort
of jocko willing style right 430 i
always see his posts but i see them at 7
00 am yeah yeah yeah precisely
so
you know so chuckles up performing again
today yeah yeah oh he seems to always uh
beat me by a few minutes unless i wake
up in the middle of the night for a
moment but uh
to really get into action because that's
going to generate its own
dopamine and adrenaline response anytime
i've worked out really early like if i
have a flight and then
you know and then moved into the other
components of my day
i find that i feel better all day long i
i also will say if i work out really
early maybe between seven and eight am
well then my first meal might land at
nine a.m so you know you need to be
flexible with some of these things but
the general principles
apply i notice that you haven't put cold
exposure on your morning routine i'm
going to guess you must have a cold tub
of some kind of you have a cold tub and
a sauna i've been less good about that
lately the best time to do that for me
is on my cardio days i do it after
because you don't want to do it post
hypertrophy because you're going to
blunt some of the responses that are
actually you're trying to get by the the
workout itself that's right and i have
one i should say i have one rest day per
week where i don't do any cardio or
weight training i really like doing
having a complete rest day but on that
complete rest day
if i can
i'll do 20 minutes of sauna and then
cold for three minutes 20 minutes of
sauna and then cold i'll make the rest
day reparative and generally we make
that social where we're talking about
things and and we're very social in our
working out like we we talk
my partner and i talk while we work out
i you know when it's set when it's time
to do a set i become a little bit of
like the drill sergeant so let's do your
set do your set but then occasionally
i'm the guy doing a set and i'm like all
right so this afternoon we're gonna you
know
but i try and i try and really focus and
i enjoy training by myself too but
generally we train together and then
and then typically if we're doing ice
bath or something we try and coordinate
those things so i've seen a bunch of
research about sauna i've seen a bunch
of research about cold exposure contrast
therapy which is huge here in austin
going from sauna to cold and it seems
like 20 and three three rounds is very
typical
is there something that we're gaining or
something that we're losing
by doing that cycle rather than doing a
block of heat and a block of cold
separately
not that i'm aware of but you know that
we finally have some good science to put
to this and unfortunately it wasn't from
my lab this is the beautiful work of
susannah soberg who's over in
scandinavia published a paper in sell
reports medicine showing that the
threshold you're trying to hit each week
is at least you can do more but at least
11 minutes of uncomfortable but safe
cold exposure
per week total so that could be three
minutes monday three minutes wednesday
so yeah so on to 11 minutes and 57
minutes per week minimum
size that's what they found
what did they find increases brown fat
thermogenesis
thereby metabolism thereby comfort being
you know in cold etc um
clearly there's a resilience effect
clearly there's a dopamine increasing
effect and clearly you can do more you
could do all that in one day or you
could spread it out throughout the week
or you could do more it kind of depends
on what you're shooting for how cold
people always say how cold how hot well
for heat
is generally uh between 187 degrees
fahrenheit and 212 degrees fahrenheit
somewhere in that range and for cold
it's
cold enough that you really want to get
the hell out but that you can stay in
safely because i don't want anyone to
kill themselves but doing this stuff did
i see you say that um
evening time
heat exposure increases growth hormone
release by 16 times or something insane
but subsequent
sessions of the same only increase it by
a very small margin yes am i talking
about my asset no you're absolutely
right so we can
we can delineate some protocols
if you want to get better more resilient
cold exposure is going to be great
anytime
post cold exposure your body is going to
heat up
think of your body heating up as waking
up so if you are concerned about not
being able to sleep then i would suggest
you do your cold exposure earlier in the
day right
heat does the opposite so i'm laying out
some parameters here heat does the
opposite you're going to heat up while
you're in the deliberate heat exposure
but afterwards there's a post heating
dip in temperature we talked this was
all covered in an episode with dr craig
heller on thermogenesis gets a little
bit down in the weeds but take my word
for it if you want to get the science
you can go there to find the science
behind this
so sauna at night is great
as well now let's think about how to
combine these things so let's say you
you know you're on it's a tuesday you've
done your weight training on monday
and you want to do your heat and cold
you don't have time to optimize
everything perfectly you could say okay
i'm going to do my
heat and cold at 10 a.m or 8 a.m you get
in the sauna for 20 minutes or so and
then you get into the cold for three
minutes
and then you might get into the sauna
again for 10 minutes
and you get in the cold for another
minute or so you end on cold yes why
because it'll wake you up and presumably
you're not you want to be woken up for
the day that also means don't then if
you're doing it in a facility don't then
go and have a warm shower right once
you've finished right coolest shower is
fine because you want to clean off often
i mean the ice bath is cleanish but it's
you know
depends where you're going in
laboratories you're absolutely right in
laboratories if we want to preserve
something in particular a virus we put
in the freezer if you want to kill a
virus you heat it up
just as i have as dirty of a sauna as
you want but the cold tub well yeah the
sauna sort of its own autoclave if it
gets hot enough right and the cold cold
stuff needs to be cleaned out now and
again you get mold growing in a in a
freezer which is kind of freaky to think
about but you really can't it's never
going to grow in a sauna never going to
grow if it if it gets hot enough now
there is what i call the soberg
principle
which is if you are using deliberate
cold exposure to increase metabolism end
on cold so finish on the cold not just
because it wakes you up more but because
then you have to heat your body up
naturally which is a thermogenic
metabolic response
so end with cold and if you really want
to push it you can do things like don't
use a towel use evaporation
spread out your limbs and don't huddle
so that you have to shiver more etc i
mean a lot of little games you can play
but let's say you want to reduce post
exercise inflammation you're not
concerned with hypertrophy gains of
muscle size gains or strength gains well
then get in the cold after your your
workout do that for one to some people
can do 10 minutes reduce inflammation
let's say you really want to hit growth
hormone which is what you asked
the biggest effects of sauna on growth
hormone and they are big effects are
when the sauna is only done once per
week but it's done in four cycles or
sets we could say of 30 minutes each so
that means 30 minutes in the sauna at
the temperatures i described before then
a five minute break just air cooling off
or 10 minute break then back into the
sauna for 30 minutes this is brutal then
again in the afternoon 30 minutes in the
sauna
then
10 minutes just air cooling off and then
back into the sauna for 30 minutes so
that's two hours
at 187 to 212 degrees one day in one day
with a maximum of what less than sort of
20 minutes
of rest in between those little sessions
than the big rest in between so you have
to be very careful right heat can kill
you you got to hydrate you need to make
sure you get enough salt like it i mean
this is this is work right um but you
get you see in these human studies up to
16-fold increases in growth hormone so
you can imagine this could exert some
very strong reparative effect if you're
training for a big event or endurance
event or maybe you're just really wiped
out from the week this is a stressor but
it's a stressor that delivers a potent
growth hormone response now if you do
sauna more often than that
you're not going to want to do two hours
a day in the sauna because presumably
you're doing other things you have a
life you have a life and in addition to
that the growth hormone effect starts to
diminish if you become too heat adapted
and that raises a more interesting
question perhaps which is why is it that
this two-hour protocol really works if
you do it once a week to increase growth
hormone it's because it's a stressor and
certain stressors increase growth
hormone
does it have to be heat no you probably
also do four really long rounds of ice
bath and i'm guessing you'd probably see
a similar effect no one's ever really
looked you'd probably see a similar
effect because it's all about the stress
stimulus now those that work on exercise
science and weight training would
probably say yeah you could also do a
this has been shown you know a 90 minute
10 sets of 10 multiple exercises for 10
sets of 10 high volume german volume
training work out and get the same
growth hormone effects there's so many
studies like this
i personally like to do the sauna two or
three days a week
and if i'm traveling off and don't get
the opportunity if i'm in austin it's
great because there are all these sauna
places but if i'm traveling abroad i
don't have the time then i might do i
might take a day i'm thinking wow i did
three podcasts i'm exhausted when i'm in
new york i like to go to a place i have
no relation to them but i think it's
called spa 88 it's a russian banya
and i'll just go for the whole day
if i've been working really really hard
they serve food there they sort of
borscht and all this other kind of like
pickled vegetables and um they must
think that you're russian you they must
you must walk through the doors and they
go hello brother sometimes i usually
just don't the best way to to appear
russian lex i hope you're listening is
just not saying anything just just
that's the most russian thing that you
can say is nothing exactly very stoic
um that place is great and they have
different saunas steam sauna they have
cold dunk and sometimes i'll just spend
three four hours there there's one in
san francisco called archimedes banya
so sometimes that's an occasional thing
now most people are trying to
incorporate this into their daily life
and just like as we said for ice bath if
you don't have access to ice or ice bath
or cold tub you do cold shower
or longer cool baths with heat i realize
not everyone has access to a sauna hot
baths do work now one thing about hot
baths and hot sauna is they will nuke
your sperm that is not nuke a nuke is a
you know slang they will reduce viable
sperm count so for males that are trying
to reproduce you know trying to create
children
you want to be careful about hot baths
and hot sauna too often some people will
bring a cold pack in and put in their
groin you can't do that in a bath
but
i mean sperm are maintained outside the
body the testicles are maintained
outside the body
um you're right the scrotum has varying
elasticity in order to maintain
temperature of the sperm that's why that
that's the the various effects that have
been described are there on purpose um
so
why
human evolution design this way i don't
know someone will say but
in any case
unless you're
trying to you know and again the ice
pack approach is interesting um some
people do that actually there's a kind
of interesting relationship between cold
and testosterone and thermogen and
spermatogenesis there is a little
cottage industry out there i think on
amazon people will buy these gel pack
underwear of cool i think they're called
snowballs
this is
cooling the scrotum in order to try and
increase spermatogenesis okay now i'm
not aware of any data on this but people
report anika data and have shown their
blood work and stuff
that it
it actually works to increase
testosterone levels i am not aware of
any periodic studies i am not i'm not i
would not be sitting as comfortably as i
am right now
but but i find this sort of amusing on
the one hand and then on the other hand
i think what we're arriving at is some
general principles of physiology which
are that light
exercise
temperature
both heat and cold are all very powerful
stimuli for creating hormonal and
neuromodulator dopamine epinephrine
effects and when you start to dig
beneath the surface of all these
protocols wim hof breathing ice baths
sauna
snowballs what you are finding is that
these are all different stimuli to tap
into these different neuromodulator
systems right you know sunlight on our
skin and on and into our eyes organizes
all these hormone cycles there's a
beautiful study out of israel just this
last year peer-reviewed study showing
that if men
and women are told to go outside and get
a lot of sunlight exposure on their skin
for 20 minutes a day three times a week
testosterone and estrogen levels go up
substantially feelings of desire and
sexual passion go up you know
there's a real effect of the summer
months
for people
and it's hormonal and that's because the
skin is an endocrine organ um
these effects shouldn't surprise us and
some people hear these and they go oh so
basically you're just telling us to like
get sunlight and exercise and eat well
and you know and avoid bright lights at
night so that you can sleep
yeah that's basically what we're saying
we're saying that because there's now
substantial physiology to support that
there's nothing new in terms of the
mechanisms the mechanisms haven't
evolved in we believe hundreds of
thousands of years if not more
the ways to tap into these systems are
many high intensity interval training
you're going to get increase in
adrenaline
yoga nidra meditation a nap you're
getting increases in serotonin so it's
not trivial though i want to be really
clear these sorts of things
are not trivial they are exceedingly
powerful because they tap into systems
that we all harbor so the beautiful
thing is they work the first time and
they work every time and there are very
few things you can say that about they
work the first time and they work every
time and the reasons they work are now
becoming clear to us through these more
high quality studies there's a lot of
conversations at the moment around
concerns for the
average amount of testosterone that men
have got estrogens in the water and
stuff like that
should we be worried how worried should
it be
so um i just recently came back from
copenhagen i was there to give a talk
for the lunbeck foundation and there was
another talk that the lundbeck
foundation put on they do a great
popular science series um
called coffee and cocktails i'm not a
drinker but people it's so european it's
it's so different than over here is
everybody's smoking outside no one was
smoking but people would bring were
allowed to bring in real glasses with
ice in them and yet the auditorium was
silent this was a big con it's in the
concert hall and copenhagen it's very
beautiful venue and you couldn't hear an
ice cube [ __ ] the entire night no clean
clink clink no no drinking of the ice
cubes people were in there with their
cocktails and enjoying enjoying science
and earlier that week there was a talk
by dr shayna swann she wrote a book
called countdown
she went on joe rogan's podcast i
believe earlier last year
she talked about
the decline of sperm counts from the
1930s until now and
ties it in a very she's a serious
researcher with national institutes of
health grants etc ties this to um the
increasing presence of phthalates the
most difficult word to pronounce in the
english language besides ophthalmology
phthalates
that are present mainly present mainly
in pesticides if you look at sperm
counts and testosterone levels in males
in different areas of the united states
they are
significantly lower in areas where
there's a lot of pesticide use in rural
areas where there's a lot of farming and
pesticides
very serious issue and in the offspring
of mothers that ingest
phthalates
there's this the anogenital distance is
what they study in the lab
the anode general distance literally the
distance between the base of the scrotum
and the um and the anus in males is much
greater than it is in females there's a
word for that females don't have a
scrotum obviously so they measure from
the base of the genitals to the base of
the vagina to the to the anus in males
they go from the base of the scrotum
depends on the study sometimes it's the
top of the scrotum um you know i always
say you know you always have to be
careful when people are measuring
anything related to genitalia because
somebody's going to cheat in the
measurement so
so in any event i don't know how they
controlled for that but she shows these
remarkable pictures in mice and in
humans of people that are exposed or
mice that are exposed to phthalates and
basically males are showing the more
female-like pattern
of of inner general distance when
they're exposed to the phthalate in
utero okay this is not post birth this
is in utero the mother's being exposed
it crosses the blood placental barrier
what's happening well this is reducing
sperm counts now what can people do
about this
well first of all there's this question
of whether or not phthalates are having
a similar effect after a child is
brought into the world
one doesn't know but we do know and this
is goes back to my early graduate work
was on the effects of androgens like
testosterone and dht on
different traits of brain and body
we know that
for instance it just very briefly that
during pregnancy the brain is organized
male by way of believe it or not
testosterone converted to estrogen
through a process called aromatization
but
the growth of the penis the fact that
there even will be a penis etc is set by
a testosterone called dht
dihydrotestosterone
testosterone converted dht through 5
alpha ductase and no no not
that's an organizing effect on the
system as they call it but then there's
an activating effect where during
puberty the testes just start producing
testosterone some is converted to dht
and the dht is what creates the growth
of the penis okay
in people that inject phthalates during
puberty and in the post-puberty years
it's conceivable that those phthalates
could inhibit the activating effects of
androgens not just what we call the
organizing effects of androgens early in
life okay why is this interesting and
important well sperm counts are
definitely going down are they going
down so much so that
people are incapable of reproducing
probably not because you know as they
told us in school it just takes one and
indeed it just takes one sperm but it is
a probability it's a numbers game right
the reason you know i people that take
anabolic steroids unless they
do things to offset the effect on their
own testosterone and sperm production
sperm counts are down so the probability
of of successful insemination is of of
the egg is reduced also it's a numbers
game so it just takes one but having
many improves the probability that the
one will be able to fertilize
so the short answer is yes i think it is
very concerning now which things should
we be concerned about my understanding
of the literature and here i'm not an
i'm now venturing into territory for
which i am certainly not an expert is
that things like plastics that have bpas
may be a concern drinking water may be a
concern but the most serious
or
enriched source of bpas are things like
printed receipts
yeah i was out for dinner the other
night it was probably about a month and
a half ago and the server came over and
i reached for the receipt and as i was
going for it like this one of the girls
who had never met before she's a creator
online
hit my hand away are you really going to
touch that
and this is the first time i've ever
heard about this this is legit yeah
printed receipts are
a a rich source of bpas and topically
that could come through this yeah it
could go trends terminally i mean now
you'd probably have to handle a lot of
receipts i mean i don't think you're
going to hear a check out cashier
perhaps this check out the thing
definitely check out cashiers and listen
it's going to vary some people are
operating with a testosterone level and
sperm count that's already back on its
heels so to speak some people have
abundant testosterone and sperm so
it's really going to depend on the
individual i don't think people should
get paranoid or delusional about any of
this but just don't start sleeping in a
bed of receipts don't start sleeping in
a better receipt that's an interesting
and there are all sorts of jokes that
could be made about that one
that i won't make but
there are also some other things like
you know do a little bit of online
research about phthalates and don't go
to fringe sites go to dr shaina swan's
website right i believe she's at mount
sinai or one of the other larger medical
schools in new york go to her website
she's a legitimate researcher and see
what's there see what the sources of
phthalates are pesticides does that mean
you should only eat organic fruits and
vegetables maybe i don't know which
pesticides people are using on which
fruits and vegetables right so there's
some research that needs to be done but
the moment we start talking this way and
people start saying oh wow this is
really like hippie science this isn't
hippie science this is
serious nih-funded researcher saying
phthalates before birth can dramatically
alter the trajectory of of the male
stability and make sperm and
testosterone
phthalates in puberty may be able to do
that but we know that that
androgens in particular dht and
testosterone converted to estrogen have
a powerful role in masculinizing the
brain and body during those years
why wouldn't people be
you know do half an hour of research
online or for instance the abundant data
that melatonin suppresses pregnant
excuse me suppresses puberty and yet
people will take melatonin like it was
you know insane
physiological levels yeah am i saying
melatonin is going to suppress your
puberty if you took it as a kid you're
messed up no and yet it's very easy to
replace it with some of the healthier
alternatives that are out there so i
think that one can have a thoughtfulness
about this stuff and some and it's
action oriented without having to really
freak out about it how do you think that
creators like derek from more plates
more dates or greg ducette are someone
who's changed the way that the internet
understands um hormonal profiles and
supplementation because since watching a
lot of derrick's stuff since he's become
big on youtube i have been much more
considering the balance that's inside of
my body but i don't think that that was
super common before guys like him were
around yeah i look derek's not a
scientist by training but he's done an
immense service to
the world because no one was talking
about this stuff it was talked about in
bodybuilding circles
where they talk very openly
it was
starting to emerge in testosterone
replacement therapy clinics and then
mostly guys were doing this stuff and
lying about it right they're doing it
but then they don't want to talk about
actually
kudos to joe rogan who years ago came
out and said yeah he decided to start
doing trt and a low dose of testosterone
he's already successfully reproduced and
so he you know he brought it up and and
you know
it's clear that this is becoming more
common
here are some of the general principles
that i think forgive me derek if i get
this wrong in terms of what you believe
because i never want to speak for
anybody else but my read of the science
and the actual protocols
speak to the idea that
many people do not need testosterone
replacement
young guys should really avoid doing
anabolic steroids it can really mess up
their system not just physically not
just for the ability to have kids later
but
lead to all sorts of sexual issues and
sexual performance issues like there
needs to be some medical incentive right
hypogonadism for instance
but
at the point where someone either has
bank sperm or decides they don't want
any more kids or is willing to do
something like take hcg to maintain
testicular and
function and spermatogenesis it's very
clear that
going with the lowest you know doctor
described right i'm not talking about
illicit use that the lowest possible
dosage of testosterone therapy is going
to be better than for instance taking
200 milligrams in a one mil injection
every two weeks right because you get
these huge increases and then these
troughs so people say something that
you've learned from derek
yes and in talking with other people and
i i'm no longer doing this um but i i
did a run of it from 45 to 46 years old
and nothing before that um and i did it
because i'm working on a on a book
really that has a whole section on
hormone therapies i wanted to see what
it was like i'll tell you basically
testosterone gives you more energy to
work more um if it's done appropriately
right maybe that's the the secret for
lex
maybe maybe it's just brimming maze
brimming and i'll say when i went into
it my levels were mid-range they were
fine high to mid-range they were kind of
like sevens eight but i was doing some
supplementation to support that i've
since gone back to that it was funny
when you say something on the internet
people think that means it's forever
right it is possible to start and come
off right so so what i've done and and
so here's what's what's relevant here
people are now
spacing out you know 30 milligrams on
monday 30 milligrams on wednesday 30
milligrams on fridays like i have a low
reasonable dose again talk to your
doctor these aren't recommended dosages
that's more typical another thing that's
really important is that people have
traditionally blocked estrogen by
increases while doing this by taking an
aromatase inhibitor novodax arimidex
these kinds of things
that
almost often is a bad idea almost often
because
having enough estrogen around allows you
to maintain
cognitive function
and libido a lot of guys think it's just
you know and it is true if estrogen is
very high and testosterone is very low
libido can suffer but if testosterone is
very high and estrogen is very low
libido can really suffer so a lot of
people who are crushing their estrogen
realize that by coming off some of those
drugs they feel far better
far more interesting far better so most
people i know that are doing this are
taking low doses of testosterone
semi-frequently throughout the week
20 to 30 milligrams every other day or
so there's a lot of variation around
this and then
not doing anything to reduce
aromatase or if they are taking very low
doses not one milligram of arimidex but
maybe something like 0.1 milligrams of
arimidex every third day or so again not
a recommendation talk to your doctor the
smarter clinics are starting to think
about this and actually i don't have any
financial relationship to derek or to
merrick health which is his clinic but
from what i understand they do a very
good job i did help them design
a herbal
mostly herbal supplement for
testosterone support for people who are
not on trt as things like tonga ali
fadoja but unbeknownst to most people i
i've not made one penny on that that was
just based on a conversation of the
research with him and dr kyle gillette
and a few other people so
estrogen can help maintain libido also
can increase libido
now here's something i learned that's
really interesting from peter atiyah
recently
women as we know make both testosterone
and estrogen and of course a bunch of
other hormones too
if they get their blood work back and
you were to adjust the
units that those hormones are measured
in nanograms per deciliter in some cases
picograms per deciliter in other cases
if you normalize them all to the same
nanograms per deciliter you would find
that a healthy woman has more
testosterone than she does estrogen
that's right
i asked him this three times i'm like
you're telling me that women have more
testosterone circulating in them than
estrogen he said absolutely now this
maybe there's a there's a caveat to that
during some phase of the menstrual cycle
but
that does not mean that their
testosterone levels are higher than that
of men
but this is remarkable right this means
that these androgens testosterone and
are doing interesting things in men
and in women and estrogen as we just
described are doing really interesting
things certainly in women and in men so
this idea of more testosterone less
estrogen good is always the case that's
simply false you have to think about
whether or not it's a man whether it's a
woman whether or not
the goal is more or less
typically people aren't going for less
libido but i suppose it's possible some
people out there with that some people
might be highly distracted by an
excessive libido right that's a
different story but
and then of course dht so i think one of
the things that derek has really
contributed to the world and i think is
important for people know that a lot of
the drugs
that are used to treat hair loss
finasteride propecia things like that
block dht receptors dihydrotestosterone
dhc is responsible for beard growth in
the face and for balding male pattern
baldness people because they want their
hair
will take these drugs if they take it in
pill form they're blocking dht
everywhere and they can experience
severe defects in libido and sexual
performance
now before that choice between your hair
and your erection for a lot of people it
is right i mean for now there are now
topical things and derek talks about all
this kind of thing they're talking
really really deep he goes really deep
into all this and what's interesting is
you know we also can take a step back
and say like what's the landscape of
health information that created this
opportunity for a kid in his 20s by the
way no one knows his last name
very clever no one knows his last name
um i'll play derek he's kind of an
avatar of a human right although he's
real um
what created this landscape for this guy
to be able to get this information out
there even though he's not a physician
he's not a scientist and i think what it
is is that he saw that there was all
this information nested in these very
niche communities that most people don't
want to look like a bodybuilder right
and yet what he did was he sort of
normalized the discussion about hormones
he normalized the discussion about other
things like dopamine and cortisol etc
and what's interesting is that science
now
is kind of following suit you know 10
years ago a discussion about hormone
therapies would never come up in the
hallways of discussions with my
colleagues since doing it an episode of
the podcast on optimizing testosterone
and estrogen no fewer than 10 of i'm not
going to name names but these are
serious scientists and it's a mixture of
men and women have approached me like
hey like what can one do in order to
adjust testosterone or estrogen levels
is
um estrogen therapy for menopause a
useful thing when should one start no
i'm not an endocrinologist so all i can
do is point them in the way of
information but this is an important
area and here's why
hormones control neuromodulators like
dopamine estrogen and so on and those
neuromodulators powerfully influence our
states of mind so if your hormones are
out of whack your neuromodulator is
going to be out of whack typically the
treatment for depression would be to go
in and just
give a serotonin reuptake inhibitor or
wellbutrin type dopamine thing and that
has its use but i love this
trend now not towards hormone therapy
necessarily but just toward a thinking a
mindset of how deep in the layers of my
biology can i go to create these sort of
waves of health that rise up to the
level of
ability to focus
and etc for so many years it's all been
attacked at the surface kind of the
waves
on the surface of the ocean and yet
there's this like we're now talking
about the deep tectonic plates movements
that are affecting all that in any case
around about 30 years ago you took a
real hard turn in life it seemed like
you drastically altered the trajectory
that you were moving on for quite a
while and i'm very interested
in how
anybody manages to make severe life
changes like that i think that many
people can
they believe that they have control over
maybe their daily habits and little
things here and there but they don't
have huge global control over their life
direction certainly not in the way
that they want
reflecting on that now
does it almost surprise you sort of the
ability that you have to be able to
change that direction it seems so
unbelievably rare
uh right so it um i don't know um i like
to think everybody harbors it inside
themselves i i can say without going
into the whole backstory because i've
done it before i mean at 19 i basically
just looked at myself and decided that i
was
a loser right i mean i was able-bodied
which was helpful i had a mind that
could remember things which was helpful
i was interested in a few things but
none of those things were setting me up
for career or ongoing progress and i had
a lot of maladaptive behaviors right at
the time i was getting involved in
fighting i just i just didn't i wasn't
completing my schoolwork i was just
really in a bad place
and
it was really fear and desperation um
mostly fear
that inspired the the switch
along the way i i haven't talked about
this publicly you know to any great
extent but along the way i hit numerous
roadblocks again and again sometimes
they were situational like people close
to me dying and the grief that came with
that sometimes it was my own kind of um
feeling like i was getting pulled back
toward a state of mind that wasn't
healthy for me uh and so on but i think
what i've
been good at
at least good at not great at but at
least good at is
finding
really good mentors that would allow me
to get to the next
node of the next milestone
and i should say that some of those
mentors were real people
that i i didn't say can you be my mentor
um not that that would be a bad thing
but
really tried to model my behavior after
people that i respected
and sometimes those mentors were people
that
i didn't know at all i mean i'll just
say this right now i mean i'm going to
embarrass him by saying it but you know
i was a junior professor meaning before
i got tenure
running a lab
i had a bulldog puppy
a laboratory and a home for the first
time in my life and feeling very very
overwhelmed and distraught and i made
many of the things that i heard tim
ferriss say
sort of central to my way of doing
things i didn't go four hours of work a
week but i did start to get extreme
about organizing my schedule so he was a
big influence on you tim huge huge and i
know tim a little bit we have some
common friends and i feel very fortunate
that now we're in touch because gone on
his podcast and gotten to know one
another but just huge i mean like there
were no organizational forces in my life
for me at that time that could help me
navigate through this landscape of you
know i'd never been a professor before i
had
taught it now it was many years ago now
but
um i knew how to do science i felt
confident in my ability to take an empty
room and a budget and create buy the
right equipment and do the experiments
hire the people i had no problem with
that but how to
regulate my time and my energy and how
to um
communicate with people i mean he had
these like little things that i don't
like the word hacks i hate it because
hacks are
implies that you're using something for
a purpose that it wasn't intended for
that's a hack but he had things like
instead of asking people um
you know like what's up when they come
in your office asking them you know what
specifically you know what what can i do
for you like what do you need really
cutting to the chase because time became
a valuable resource little things like
that tiny things on the f on the surface
that translate into huge conversion in
terms of time and energy um
and even just setting aside some savings
and things i it's not that i'm not
dumb about money but i wasn't i've never
really taken the time to think about how
i was going to invest money or do
anything so tim did a tremendous service
for for me uh without realizing it and
i've thanked him now a million times i'm
gonna thank him a million times i'm
thank you thank you tim i'm thanking you
again things like that so selecting
mentors then eventually when it came
time to start podcasting i mean lex
whether or not he knows or not you know
just thinking oh here's another guy
who's a he's a scientist he's mit
the fact he always wore that suit and
i'm gonna copy him and just always wear
the same thing because i don't have to
take guesswork i can take the guesswork
out of it there were little things that
were super deliberate that just saved me
time and energy and i think that
that's helped me along the way and then
the other thing is i have really tried
to adopt this idea that
when it's inevitable
and it will inevitably arrive that
stress grows us
that it really sharpens decision making
it really sharpens decision making and
you know if you have a very stressful
event and then you recover from it the
worst thing to do is just go and keep
going you need to take some time and
reflect about what led into that
so i've i think i'm very good at
leveraging fear into positive change if
i really think about most of the major
shifts in my life it was i'm scared as
hell to remain in this situation and i'm
very good at broadcasting fear into my
future uh you know if i've ever been in
a
bad relationship it was
clearly if i stayed in it couldn't have
been so bad that i felt like i had to
leave so i would broadcast and project
you know how horrible it would be for my
future children and i might even
build that up a little bit my system now
one could say well maybe you could have
navigated successfully i'm better at
projecting fear into my future and that
has led me to make i think better and
better decisions over time that's it how
much of the old andrew
still
rises to the surface today i know that
the music that you tend to listen to
when you're training is
still pretty punky and when i work yeah
i mean i have two very polarized
versions of music i do love you know i
love bob dylan i love joe strummer
acoustic i like i like you know i like
melodic music too but yeah i'm listening
to rance's different fingers i mean i'm
i mean i was the first ever gig i went
to
little fingers i'm jealous i've never
actually seen them play live i'm a huge
stiff little fingers fan a huge
difficult finger fan um
huge against me fan huge rancid fan i
mean you know for people that um of my
generation they probably remember it
people who are younger probably think oh
that's all 90s stuff but a lot to me i
mean i have huge collections of like 80s
and 90s music 70s music second wave punk
third wave punk i collect a ton of that
stuff i love it i mean how much of me
still exists i believe that
we are all born fundamentally with some
gift and it's our job to reveal that
gift to ourselves and you know here i'm
i want to thoroughly acknowledge someone
else who's been a great mentor without
ever meeting him because robert greene i
think is a is a wonderful fantastic guy
fantastic i've never met you robert but
i'd love to meet i mean it's one of
these things where i just put you in
touch she's been on the show twice
amazing i used to suggest the book
mastery to to graduate students and to
undergraduates like you know learn the
this process of finding a mentor um
and in science we have natural mentors
graduate advisors and postdoc advisors
and i i made sure i will say this i
should have said this earlier when a
mentor has sort of arrived in my life
either virtually or in reality i make
the most of that relationship i really
nurture those relationships i mean i
still go to visit the children of my
dead graduates
advisor
kids you know because i care so i mean
these are like these people are like
family to me how much of it still exists
well the energy has always been the same
the energy is i have an absolute
obsession from day one
this maybe was what i was kind of born
with to i like to learn things and share
them with the world i was six years old
giving lectures on monday after reading
about medieval weapons or you know
goldfish biology in class i mean my
parents thought it was crazy and they
took me a psychiatrist and i'm like no
he just really likes learning he really
likes telling people about that about
what he learns
so
and i had a little bit of an underlying
tourette's when i was younger i had a
grunting tic
i had a when i'm tired it sometimes
emerges a little bit and for me learning
and kind of seeking kind of calms that
somehow
as does training
um as a skateboarding i did boxing of
course head damage isn't good so i
stopped boxing but
that's always been in me that's how i'm
that's how my nervous system kind of
tilts left in that way
the energy
i would say i'm able to turn the dial
i'm able to tap into kind of some old
hurts and angers as fuel but i really
try and orient towards things in a very
lex friedman-ish way from a place of
light show them love show them show do
things from a place of love because it's
a more continual resource
i really believe it's this dopamine
epinephrine cycle positive feedback
cycle i really do
and so that's all there um
you know i
have pretty much eaten the same way i
have since college i've really i haven't
really changed the way i eat that much i
mean i probably ate more junk every once
in a while ice cream and pizza and stuff
and now i have less of an appetite for
but i still am the same i still train
every other day i um
i love music i love movies i love nature
i love the flora and fauna of life i
mean i have this kind of obsession with
fish tanks freshwater fish tanks i love
um
and listen i i my ex-girlfriend is a uh
she's a florist i i i developed a love
of flowers you know in those years um i
love
you know i
i'm probably the one guy who was like
wandering around in college i would go
to these like orchid festivals and some
of them look like aliens and i just i
just love learning and i love digesting
novel information
and um
and now
you know i have to say i'm in a place
where the people that i'm closest to i
mean thankfully really kind of support
that and i can indulge it through
podcasting it's so lovely now that the
environment of curiosity i think that
podcasts and and youtube and
creators have
engendered it's so cool you know the
fact that you get to
find out about something that you really
care that you would have done right you
would have done it for free without
anybody else knowing about it right and
then somehow
telling other people the thing that you
found out in this version of the
simulation is called
a job or a pursuit or something it's
it's wild uh another thing
that has carried over from your youth
are your tattoos
which i've heard you talk about
but never seen
what's your relationship with your
tattoos and why has no one ever seen
them yeah um yeah actually it was tim
ferriss that outed me on this one he was
like i found a picture on the internet
with you in full sleeves um
yeah you know i believe that you know
tattoos are i mean this has come as no
surprise or a
literal expression of what we feel on
the inside and you know i and i'm not
recommending this kids don't do this i
started getting tattooed really young
how again about 14 i got my first tattoo
no way we did them ourselves within your
first one please don't know please no
one do this india inc and a needle and
um we used to do these it's really bad
they're called knick-knack tattoos or we
kind of would do this at home don't do
it it's really bad you get bad
infections they're ugly they
they
blur they bleed that's not good um yeah
i started getting tattooed i when i was
a kid and growing up skateboarding in
the punk rock scene there were these
guys in the town where i lived they
called themselves the yahtzee guys i
don't know why i don't know what that
was about but they all had full sleeves
and they were super nice guys and they
were all into skateboarding and
you know and vehicles and i just looked
up to these guys i thought ah like
someday i want full sleeves i
yeah i've i've got full sleeves i'm
basically like neck to neck to wrist
some chest piece as well yeah but yeah
back's covered yeah nothing on my legs
nothing on my stomach ribs yeah tops of
my tops of my shoulders and um i got a
big picture of costello my dog back
there i've got a picture of his paw back
there i've got a picture of another dog
he used to have um there's still some
space for a few things there's some
things very personal to me um is that
the reason that you prefer not to show
them yeah you know i think that there
are a couple reasons i'll just be clear
as to why first of all um when i show up
to podcast it's the same way i show up
to lecture in the
classroom auditorium
and i
swear in my life this is my mindset and
this is my mantra when i do it i'm there
to teach it's not about me it's about
the student it's about the people
learning
i don't want it ever to be about me i
don't want the focus to be on me i mean
obviously i'm the voice and the person
talking but i really want people to
internalize the information and i do
think that the tattoos because they have
nothing to do with the information are a
distraction they're just a distraction i
i don't know it would sort of like be
wearing like a bright yellow shirt or
something it's not my style i prefer to
kind of make myself disappear as much as
i can
um and let the information come forward
that's you know even when i gave
scientific lectures which i still do of
course for my my professor job
i generally liked the room to be pretty
dark and i wanted the light to be on the
data on the slides i was happy to do the
voice but i want people thinking about
the data
so podcasting is a little different you
come through as a voice not or on
youtube a voice in an image but i really
prefer that it not be about me now
there's a human element too and i think
things have changed a lot when i was
growing up tattoos were not accepted
there are many work environments where
if you have for instance
where
people prefer that their surgeon or
their doctor not have tattoos some
people might prefer their surgeon or
doctor have tattoos when i was growing
up if you had a
i never had one but if someone had a
nose ring they had to cover it up with a
band-aid or take it out if they worked
at the coffee shop remember that you
probably don't you're probably young
enough no or that or eyebrow ring think
trends have changed right things have
changed and i'm kind of old school
because i'm kind of old now 46. um and
the etiquette for me has always been to
you know and this is lex does this too
is i i personally
find that if i can just show up as
formal and consistent as possible that
people at least know that i'm taking
them seriously so i don't really do it
for me i pretty much do it for the
audience
um
and also none of the tattoos are like
that interesting it's my dog i've i
really like raptors i've got a bunch of
birds i've got i mean i have all sorts
of different things raptors like the
dinosaur no raptors like um red tail
hawks and blue you know i like birds i
had either dinosaurs or trucks yeah like
yo you really need to love ford raptors
no no no ford raptor i drive a toyota
forerunner and i love it i got one truck
and i love that thing um although with
gas right now i mean it's you kind of
gotta wonder about having a gas driven
vehicle like a forerunner in any case
yeah the tattoo thing i would say for
for younger people coming up just be
aware that you can't control other
people's perceptions either and so you
know i always made it a point that i
didn't want things on my knuckles i
didn't want them on my hands i didn't
want them on my neck i didn't want them
on my face do i judge people when they
have them no but do i want them for me
no i also think that this is very
neurosciencey
as neuroscience is that we have
dedicated brain areas called fusiform
gyrus it's a face area that's dedicated
to the processing of faces even if i
just put two dots and a line in between
them on a piece of paper you see that as
a face
when one puts a tattoo on their throat
or on their face it actually changes the
way that the face is perceived right i
mean it almost looks like another mouth
there right it's a very different look
it's it can be a little bit jarring i'm
not saying one shouldn't have it but it
can be a little bit jarring it's it
changes the look of the person forever
it's not just that it's above the
neckline is that it kind of competes
with the processing of their face in its
normal way and so for me whenever i see
somebody with a throat tattoo or a face
tattoo sort of like it's hard to orient
around that and i think there's some
biology to uh to that relates to that
but like when it comes down to it i mean
people need to be individuals and live
their life the way they want to live
their life i've also never been that
much of an iconoclast i'm not
you know i'm i grew up in the punk rock
thing um you know i hate in group out
group stuff i always had friends from a
lot of different you know friends that
are jocks and hippies and punk rockers
and you know straight and gay like i
don't care as long as people are living
in their best life and they're not
harming anybody like i'm like great go
for it i i'm very laid back in that way
of course if people are harming other
people
then i believe that like
liberty and independent freedom i mean
liberty is you know one of the highest
things so you know for me so
but i don't tend to i don't consider
myself a very judgmental person but you
can't always control the perceptions of
others so i just think people should be
thoughtful about what they want to
accomplish in life in terms of a life
mission and just ask whether or not some
of the permanent cosmetic changes they
might make might might align with
compete with or be neutral for those
life missions my life mission is very
simple i want to teach people the beauty
and the utility of biology i'm going to
do that today i'm going to do that until
i take my last breath in one form or
another because that's what excites me
and that's like what keeps the dopamine
cranking dudes let's bring this one home
look i really really appreciate you uh
the work that you've done the fact that
i feel like i have a lot more agency
over my life because
i understand that my internal processes
are something that i can influence you
know the first time that i heard you say
that you cannot control the mind with
the mind a lot of different things
clicked for me so i'm very glad that lex
bullied you or convinced you to start
doing your show and uh yeah i'm looking
forward to hearing a lot more of what
you've got to do in the future well
thanks so much and thanks for bringing
me on today obviously uh we've been in
touch and i uh
align with you and i feel resonance
along the
life as podcaster right but also we've
had a chance to interact a few times i'm
looking forward to more because i think
what you're doing bringing knowledge to
the world is is so important and i so
appreciate your your questions and
learning from you i'm also going to get
these resources about the expectation
effect and the rest i've been taking
notes here because i i'm obsessed with
learning so why should people go people
want to make sure that they they listen
to more watch more follow more of your
stuff where should they go thanks for
asking yeah it's uh very straightforward
huberman lab
is the podcast and it's all the standard
places youtube apple spotify et cetera
huberman lab on twitter huber and lab on
instagram and the twitter and instagram
mainly are short content i used to do a
lot more hand drawings and i think
you're doing instagram pretty much as
well as any science communicator that
i've seen i don't think there's anyone
else that's optimized it better than
that thanks right now thanks yeah i try
and answer comments and respond to
things and um any of those three places
and we have a website which is
hubermanlab.com
that where all the podcast episodes are
links to all things in all formats we
have a newsletter and you know people
can peruse that if they want it's all i
should say zero cost to access so that's
been a major goal that we've stuck to
which is to just we don't put anything
behind a paywall the information that's
there is the information that anyone can
access dude i appreciate you let's go
and get hot and cold let's do it what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace